Um, yeah. Honestly, Missy Elliot's kind of got a point here.
It might be fun to just take Tommy's side for the rest of this.
Honestly, you know what? Yeah. You know what? Ch is a It was
really embarrassing when Chud did not go and watch his video
on stream. He thinks Chud didn't watch the video at all. What
he doesn't realize is Chud watched the video and was too scared
to respond. Could not respond and would not put that on stream
because he had no answer. That's it's just like it's undeniable
facts. That's the thing is Tommy is they call Tommy the fax machine.
Okay. Well,
Christ broadcast.
Oh my god. Yo, so no the the biggest problem in the universe
opening is awesome every single time. Look, I am not. Yeah, it's
okay when you have viewers. If you have viewers, then you can
pull off stuff like that. But when you're doing this like five
people, it's like, what are we doing?
True. Of 50 minutes of going, I don't know.
Like, I don't understand.
I I don't understand. I watch absolutely everything on YouTube
that I can, but I'm not going to watch his video so I can say
I don't understand. Well, um I
did Cha actually not watch the video. That's mad disrespectful.
That's snake behavior. He did watch the video. He didn't react
to it, right? Well, Tommy's saying he didn't watch the video,
right? I think that's who he's talking about right now. Yeah,
he's he's probably misinterpreting what Chad said. I'm not going
to watch it as in I'm not going to watch it on stream. I think
he probably did watch it off stream. Do you think Tommy's a little
bit He called Chutter Snake and he didn't even get a video featured
on the channel. Couldn't even get a react out of him. He's like
actually starting drama. stirring drama. Still not the response.
Just get just get me I have a solution. Ch. If you watched the
video, uh, you might have understood, but the problem with that
is you would you might have had some uncomfortable questions.
So, I understand. So, in true chop in the point fashion, and
we're going to be totally fair here, we're going to pretend not
to watch your video, too. That's what we're going to do. That's
our plan. All right. So, wow. I just I don't know. I I I don't
understand.
I I didn't watch. I I was just like, "Oh my god." Like, where
is this going right now?
Not seething. Oh my god. Um Yeah. Honestly, Missy Elliot's kind
of got a point here. It might be fun to just take Tommy's side
for the rest of this. Honestly, it's going to be boring. You
know what? Why not get tamed? It's like It's actually going to
be It's actually like 40 minutes just like, you know? Yeah. You
know what? Ch there's a ch there's a it was really embarrassing
when Chud did not go and watch his video on stream. The reason
and by the way I I will say Tommy's a little bit misunderstanding
here but he's his misunderstanding is actually helping Chud cuz
he thinks Chud didn't watch the video at all. What he doesn't
realize is Chud watched the video and was too scared to respond.
Could not respond and would not put that on stream because he
had no answer. That's just like it's undeniable facts. That's
the thing is Tommy is they call Tommy the fax machine. Okay.
Well, Jesus Christ. And like yeah, obviously the Boast comment,
you Chud's son, you couldn't even deny that Chud just probably
leaked that for fun cuz he's a snake. Amazing. But I promise
you won't see either. I'm not going to pull the Esan thing over
and over again. Um Oh, watch my video. Watch my video. I don't
give a damn if he watches or not. I don't give a rat's ass. I'm
going to uh clarify some things and uh you know they were they
were cute. They were cute. They tried to do they basically did
everything I thought and the fact that he's playing stupid.
Hold on. I'm opening up my messages to right now and letting
him know that actually it's not working. Tommy is too smart
for us. This plan will never work. I've let I've let Chud know.
Okay. Tommy's too smart. the plan won't work. We're stupid fence
rider bit over and over again. Didn't shock me all that much
and uh I'm going to show you why I don't like this guy and I
have even more reason not to trust him than before because that's
what it's all about. It's it's about like I don't trust that
guy. I want nothing to do with him. Right. I was right. What?
You could have called me. What? That is what Ch's like. That
is Ch. If you're going to pretend it was pretty much exact. Yeah,
it was pretty much exact. Not to know what's wrong by not watching
the video. We're gonna pretend we didn't watch a video. That's
That's pretty much uh where we're going uh for it because you
can Yeah, you can avoid the um the uh No, we didn't bring up
the Boax thing. Come to think of it. Um you can avoid the fact
that you you spilled on Boax. We had everything on Boax. And
what a bad person. We didn't have to out him. Boax, you did it
on purpose cuz you're a content. We didn't have to. H I'm taking
aside. Yeah, it was like, dude, they talked all kinds of insane
in these group chats for days and weeks and months and they didn't
leak it. They were just behind the scenes being like, "This guy's
disgust. This guy's such a loser." Can you imagine that this
guy messaged me a hundred times while I was putting LEDs on my
mini fridge and what a loser he is? They did that a lot and they
never leaked it, which is cool and awesome. Suck. I mean, it
wasn't enough for you. They probably wouldn't have found his
stupid Only fans if it wasn't for you. That That's a good reason
not to trust you. Hey, oh,
okay. Sorry. I
I agree with Tommy. I'm defending Tommy. I think that uh Chud
mentioning the dress thing made it so the throwaway guy was on
the lookout when Bob opened up his list of Gmail accounts and
showed the Gmail account that corresponded to the Only Fans account
and used the same username. I think that the dress thing put
that in Throwaway's head and so only because of that did he pause
and examine the Gmail the Gmail accounts on on screen. Okay.
When was Mr. Manshi Hehei first made on Only Fans and first posting
to Reddit? Was it before or after January 1st? Do we have a timeline
on this? Mr. Mani He Mr. Mani He fans in the chat who could give
us a date on when the first Reddit posts were. Oh, got a couple
bashful people in chat not willing to engage and actually give
their knowledge to us. That's kind of [__] up. But
because honestly, if uh it was before January 1st, I feel like
there's a chance that Chud didn't even need that leak. He probably
was just trolling whatever subreddit Bob was posting on and found
that found that organically. Okay, that's true. And and leaking
the dress thing was just knowing what he could set in motion.
And Tommy has picked that up once again that Chud is dishonest.
He's operating on a different level of of snakehood. Okay. And
and this is what he did. He saw organically the post of Boaxs.
He decided he was going to leak it and and get everybody. He
he put throwaway on it. Okay. It's crazy. It's crazy. What's
crazier though to me is that Tommy can see through the matrix
and understand these things without any actual firsthand knowledge.
That's what's more insane to me. My experience, you want to How
do you able to predict everything? Look at the way people you
trust treat people. Sorry, that was an awesome unp.
That's a that's a really really good indicator on what you're
in store for, you know. And by the way, apparently this game
is a a bit of a shock to me. I'll admit
um I'm not the only one that believes
uh that you you played
um fast with the Oh,
no. No. Did you get your 30 pieces of silver queen? You get your
30 pieces of silver, you snake. That's what I thought. This is
the thing though. It's like so crazy that that Yeah, I can say
I think Chud is is and I think absolutely he knew that was private
and you leaked it anyway. Me and Ch are still fine. It's not
the end of the
But for these people it would be for Tommy. It seems to be like,
"Oh yeah, this should be it." It's just so strange. I don't
January 9th. Ah. Well, thanks Mr. John backs, thank you for looking
into that and finding it out. Unfortunately, my theory is not
not holding white, not holding water. Yeah, I I don't know. Would
it Here's the thing. It's pretty It's kind of annoying to leak
that, but like at what point am like I in a random place and
getting leaks of Boax's like mental breakdowns from randoms?
Like I'm I'm in a group call with like a a couple commentary
people and and me not knowing any of these not knowing really
the commentary people or Bos. I'm in calls where this getting
leaked and they're laughing about his like mental breakdowns
over DM. Like I I don't know. It didn't seem like they were really
keeping it that tight-knit. Like it didn't leak but me. Yeah.
I don't know. Six months go by. Nobody makes a video on him in
his dress. And I don't know. I don't know. Let me get this fixed
real quick. Uh, remember he tried to do the same thing with Papa
Gut like he did to you? Yeah. Oh, did he do the definition game?
I don't know. I heard I should really watch that and I might
do it. The whole papa gut thing. I'm I'm looking forward to that.
All right. Here's Queing everybody. But um, if I were to totally
still man it, I did say in the conversation with Bolex, I don't
want to see you wearing the dress. And everyone had made a big
deal out of that. So maybe he assumed that Nick had said something
about it. I don't know. Oh, I I think it's a reach cuz I think
I explicitly told shot it was it was private. Yeah. Yeah. So
I think you know deliberately linking it to be honest. Oh. Uhoh.
Super big criticism. There's some teeth to Tommy's criticism
here now. Oh, in more ways than one truth. I won so hard. I guess
up. You love to see it. late night friend. Yeah. So, I'm not
the only one that believes this. And by the way, this guy's going
to take your audience 100%. You don't have to worry about Nick
not shouting you out. You don't have to worry about Willie being
nice to you. He's going to take your audience because willing
to do what Chud wants. I have a
to dubious as [__] Right out in the right out in
the open. Like completely out in the open. Like what did he say
about me? I would never bend over backwards for my friends. um
like Tommy C does. Yeah. Guilty. And he would rather suck. I
think he'd do it either way. So remember the context here. He
he was saying that he was claiming that I apologized to Nick
for watching a video about him. That's what Tommy was was claiming
I did. So that's what I'm saying is that is a ridiculous thing
to suggest that you would apologize to someone for watching a
video about them. Unless obviously I had something totally crazy,
you know.
Uh, I just I don't understand where he's uh like honestly all
you have to do like I feel like how are you how are you taking
audience members? Like what are you doing to do it? You're showing
up. I I don't know like where I don't know where he's coming
from. Like it's not it's not even about what people get upset
about. It's like if you're just talking about stealing audience.
If stealing audience were as good or as easy as like leaking
secrets about people, then I don't know. There'd be a lot of
like far less funny people who have audiences, right? Yeah, for
real. Like there are lots of stakes out in the world. That's
not how you steal an audience. You don't just like selectively
leak one negative thing about them and oh, I've got half of your
audience now. It's just like it's and it's never even like a
it's never really a zero sum game. Like generally, I think Rising
Tide lifts all votes, right? that you know if people are collaborating
regularly and like that and as people get more popular even if
they disagree on stuff they don't necessarily steal audience
from from each other often times just increases like the size
of the space they're in if you know what I mean. Yeah. I I think
basically that's how I look at it is like if we have if I have
people on my stream and we make like funny content together that's
going to get viewers from their audience to come watch me and
vice versa. Vice versa. Exactly. Yeah. I mean, I guess if we
if we stream like on a perfect overlap, maybe that would be some
kind of concern for me, but I probably wouldn't be I'd probably
just still keep doing it. Like, what's the what's the ultimate
downside there that they take I don't even know how they would
take all of your audience, right? I would imagine it would just
wouldn't work like that. It would be like, you know, you you
get like a small downturn like you get like maybe like you're
say you're at 600 viewers usually. you might be at 500 or 400
maybe viewers when they're live at the same time or something
if they get really big and they have a huge amount of your audience.
But even that is difficult and like I would just say it probably
just goes to like different topics, right? Like I would I would
assume like ultimately if the other person is just better than
me on every single topic, they're just more funny, more witty
all the time. I have like it's like okay I'm just going to say
I don't know what to say. I'm just like what am I supposed to
do? Yeah, exactly. And then you would probably benefit from having
them around to be honest at that point. Anyway, if they're really
I guess so. Yeah. I just that's just how it is. I don't know.
Like there's just no
Yeah. There's nothing else to say. So kiss the Oreos. Yeah. Anyway,
ask for 200 viewers.
I got to be honest with you. I think if I kissed Dioro's ass,
I'd want a little more than 200 viewers. But hey, I mean, Jesus
Christ. And by the way, Queenman, I've never been raided by Dioro.
Not once. Only Chad. And that didn't do me all that much. Ah.
Do you think it Do you think it uh burns burns? Do you think
it uh grinds his ears that you've been raided by Nick a couple
times? Do you think that upsets him? I have to wait for just
one sec. Good at the end of the day. Wait, am I waiting for you
or the video yet? Yeah. So, but let's get to the heart of this
thing. I think you have. What? Yeah, I think you have. Oh, been
rated my dick.
Yeah, I think he's like sent his viewers. Our times are just
so different though. Our times are so dramatically different.
If I was raided, it was one stupid, you know, I didn't get the
uh the five point. So, nobody would have ever fact.
No, I never got I don't know. If I got rated by him now, it'
be awesome. But, um yeah, whatever. Uh the other thing um and
these are the list of things why I don't trust you. You know,
the list of things you didn't talk about. Uh this this was very
important video putting pressure on Turkey Tom for his association
with DGG knowing damn damn well Tommy Tommy was already moving
away from it. I saw somebody sent me a clip of reviewing this.
I listen I realize of like um I don't I I don't want to go after
Tom, but I think I think Tommy's got the timeline wrong. I think
a lot of people had the timeline very wrong on this, but I'm
keeping He was in a tough spot. He couldn't say anything about
Destiny or throw him under the bus until why. He literally he
literally did. But I I don't know. I don't know how to look at
it because I don't know if Tom did it because of the Pixie stuff
or if he really did just do it because of the like accusations
that he was the guy getting blown. I don't think that could possibly
be it, but it's one of the like day two of after the leaks. I
feel like it was about the Pixie stuff like day one or two of
the leaks. Like it was about everyone commenting to him saying
he was gay and that was him in the video and people that was
him in the video and he was sick of associating with the degenerate
cuz it would be called gay stuff video or some [__]
like that. Well and I think he was going to start pulling away
anyway cuz like Destiny was kind of just being totally unhinged
to his friends, right? And Tom came and was like, "Dude, what
the why are you calling my friends after I like took you out
to go shooting with them and right?" Like it was the whole thing
with uh Granthm and Brandon Herrera and
Donut Operator. Yeah, those three guys. Yeah, but it was Donut
Operator he's fighting with the most, right? I think was there
an argument with Brandon Herrera, too? I can't I think I think
Brandon Herrera
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So, like Desi was just like on these guys and
Tom like joined the VC. I remember and was like, "Hey, what the
are you doing? Like, what's going on here?" Like, you know, they're
not. And Destiny's like, "Yeah, but also I paid for that dinner."
And if that isn't just Destiny in a nutshell right there, um
I don't know what is. I paid for an entire breakfast. How dare
these guys say I wasn't cool?
Don't they know I paid for the breakfast, Tom? Did I pay for
that breakfast? Yeah, Destiny, you did. That's what I'm talking
about. Oh, god. Somebody said like their his girl was like more
interested in them than they were in him and like that set him
the off, didn't it? I can't remember that whole thing. I just
remember him being like this was this was like the most disregulated
he was I think was at this time where he's like the dude I don't
know it's like worse than um worse than the pixie [__]
was like this time he was like saying the dumbest [__]
till the story officially broke to protect the victim. you guys
are always pro clutching about. You know, the girl you really
don't care about anymore than I do. Yeah, that girl. Oh, I bro
I It's so weird when people do this like reverse concern trolling
on this stuff. I don't know. It's like very bizarre to me. Like
with no no actual understanding of any relationship dynamic just
seems weird. But
it's fine. How could you do this? How could you record somebody
without their consent? Girl, what say about me? When do I ever
pretend like I give a [__] about any of this past
like, you know, it's kind of entertaining to engage. You really
don't care about I I'm not sitting there [__] acting
like, "Oh, I really care about Pixie's feelings." No. So, I don't
want, you know, obviously I don't want to [__] her
over if I can avoid doing it [__] like that. But
fundamentally, don't like that. Concerned? No. This isn't something
I really know. I like Pixie. I would rather Pixie win and if
she asked me like a question about something, I would help, right?
But like
I I feel like I only ever represented as like this was my friend
who changed my mind was with Cherry. So I don't know. But whatever.
Whatever. I'm a Sugar and Spice fan. I'm friends with Pixie and
I'm I'm a Pixie fan, but I don't know if that makes me a friend.
Like Like we we'll we'll never get classic bits like this one
again. Hello. Oh my god. Oh. Oh no. I'll tell them. Sorry. Is
that Audacity calling? Got to Oh, yeah. That was the other thing.
I'm totally I totally like hang out with straight raid. So, I
don't know. I don't know. I don't know. Okay. Come back any day
now. I'm I'm holding out hope
any more than I do. Yeah, that girl. Oh,
The moan there is just uh it's very feels like the second half
of that sound clip. How could you do this? How could you stop
using that? Must be Yeah, that helps too, you know. Oh, by the
way, all the victims would like to give you a big thank you.
Oh. Oh. Oh, hold on. Hold on. It's actually the topic we just
talked about. It always comes back to like this. Why are these
people performatively virtue signaling over these morons? I'm
sure all of the victims of sure love review. Ultimate review.
How
is it,
dude? It's so [__] stupid. I just want if the Zangster
guy is listening, this is like this is your guy. These are the
people who are intelligent enough to make this argument, not
not willing to take any look or do any 360 observe the environment
they operate in at all. They'll just throw that out and say like,
"Oh, that's a good point. I heard my milk make the point. I'll
make the point, too." Oh, and victims, too, because Queen and
Chud and the rest of these guys, you actually don't need to interact
cuz they're all people. Thank you very much. All these guys have
done those people no favors at all. It's always hard to know
that allegations, but his convenient overlooking of the explicit
BLX allegation was telling the Tommy. Yeah, of course. 6 months
over there. I forgot we were supposed to be Huh. We were supposed
to be on his side. God damn it. I totally forgot about the bit.
It's going to be hard to maintain the bit to be honest with you.
Six.
And keep in mind, I want you to keep in mind about the Bobax
allegation. Everybody thought enough was enough. It wasn't enough
for Chud to be in the biggest stream of the year. A New Year
stream with Turkey. A new year stream. It's on, dude. It's so
bro. It's so
This is This is so disgusting. And that it's just transparent.
Like appar I hope Tommy's just like having a senility moment
on his own because I swear to God if they look at it as like
who will we honor with being on our Call of Duty New Year's stream.
Who will we give? Who will we bestow this gift upon? It's not
a friend stream. We're not friends hanging out. We're not like
friendly co co-workers hanging out. This is an opportunity for
somebody. And I think we'll bequeath it to Chud Logic. He has
been loyal. Okay. We covered his thing. We uh we looked the other
way and now he's uh he's entering straw man.
What's that? The joke. That's a straw man.
Never mind. Oh, right, right, right. Sure, sure, sure. Don't
spoil. I knew your stream would It's just like Yeah. The whole
idea that this is like a thing where it wasn't like friends or
any at all. It was like just um it was like a business opportunity.
I feel like almost certainly Chad didn't look at it that way.
Like it can be both, but I'm saying that if you look at his uh
I guess we're we're going to give a business opportunity to the
best guy. I just don't I can't see it. I can't see that for the
vibe of that stream overall.
Anyway, that's golden. That's a
opportunity.
And I guess he needed more content. He's probably probably He's
probably God. I can't wait. He He probably I couldn't believe
it took as long to believe he did. He probably couldn't uh he
probably couldn't believe it. and then you know it's a safe thing
to leak because nobody likes Bobacks. So that's the one of the
things to avoid. The other thing was putting Turkey Tom under
pressure. You knew damn well his situation and you kept pressing
him. You all can go back and and watch it and you can see do
knowing damn well Turkey Tom couldn't run his mouth and had to
keep the rouge off of Destiny so he didn't get tipped off. What
the was Turkey Tom? Okay. Like what what why do we let people
operate this way that nobody I still don't know? It was all public
information. Chud was talking off of public information. If Tom
hadn't looked into it or had no idea, he should just say, "I
have no idea." Right? Stuff that Chud was really pressing Tom
about was being afraid of DG and pressing Tom and Nick about
being afraid afraid of the audience. And they were denying that,
but then Nick admits that in private Sunday. So, I mean, well,
hold on. I don't even think that was the biggest press. The biggest
press to me was when he was like, "No, there's no way you would
say it was consensual." Cuz Tom was going, "Well, we have no
way to know if it's consensual." The actual press was on that,
right? That was to me the actual press. Like the actual
press of when cuz Tommy said pressing on the association with
DG or some. So I I I feel like he's more to Tommy Tommy says
that's the big one. But to me it was the like No, no, no. I just
don't think it's consensual. So, I think Tommy just doesn't understand
what the big thing was in that stream cuz the thing where Tom
got really uncomfortable and Chud was like, "No, you're full
of right now was on saying, "Oh, well, we it probably was consensual
or something, right?" They're dogging on Molina instead of addressing
the pixie stuff. Yeah. And Chud was just saying like on balance
it probably not consensual, right? And they weren't willing to
give that. They're like, "Well, no, we really don't know." And
Chud was like, "Okay, pretending we really don't know." Yeah.
Anyway, because it was right after they all got the Aerodite
DMs. I understand it was after the Aerodite DMs or whatever.
I know that. Um, yeah, I know that. And maybe maybe they didn't
want to say like, "Oh, it's clearly not consensual." Maybe there's
some thought there, but I I don't know. I don't know. In any
case, I think it's like fine for Chuck to just say his opinion
there. That was the lousiest thing to do. What What is he angry
about? It came out of left field. Watch the video. That's It's
just that simple. Watch the video. Very, very simple. But now,
I'm going to get into why I really can't stand this guy. And
this is one small example that I bet you've run into. I'll give
you a hug that you see this all the time. He's talking out both
sides of his mouth, saying something's good and bad in the same
sentence. This is my personal favorite. Thanks, Willie Mack cuz
he reminded me of this belief. But it's unquestionable. There
was absolutely this, if you want to call it networking that occurred.
And she told me crazy how that works. Oh, wait a minute. I got
the wrong clip.
We've also got a couple of people in chat. that you may want
to hear out. Um, this is his moment. How does he have the wrong
clip? This is like This has to be like double his viewership
for this, right? I feel like I got I got linked to his stream
like 5 minutes into it. This has to be his big moment. Somebody
had like 350 views or something for sure. Gammy Prism asked,
"Why not just call Ched offline and talk?" We'll get to that.
We'll get to that. We'll get to that for all the All right. First,
for those other two reasons, he's that dishonest. And then we
we'll get to that. That'll be covered. I promise. And um another
one was Queman has nothing to do with Bob or Tom. What are you
talking about? I didn't bring up Queman as far as I just brought
up Quean in the context of um he agrees with me. I didn't say
they had anything to do with Bob or Tom. I mean, obviously the
first stream was significantly about uh Queen, but I'm talking
about Chud here, not Queen.
Sermy's chat now in this chat. I've gained more respect for Quean.
If you want to know what Chuck's thinking, just ask Queman. Queenman
just has the bolts to say. So true, Tommy. That's actually Hold
on. Actually, Tommy Tommy CW, this guy is in the DMs all the
Sorry. I just want to start down there to see if you jump in
front of it again. No, no, no, no. I never messaged Chad about
anything. I've never done that. I just hate this narrative that
I'm like [__] trying to turn Chance people by sending
in [__] DMs. Get on script. It's just so [__]
annoying. All listen, so I've literally never done that. It's
just like it's the most annoying [__] ever cuz it's
like I I could have done that. I could have just started [__]
[__] talking guys, but I specifically don't. Hold
on. Where's uh where is this? Where is this? Where is this? Where
is this? Queen. No, no, no, no. This is like Chud actually. He
can only do this impression. Oh, do I not have it? Oh, god damn
it. I'm looking for my grappler hands. Where are my grab hands?
for the [__] the
that's like that's literally psychological damage from Quean
actually doing that to his brain. Okay, that's Queman like tapping
Chud's gray matter. It's like imprinted into Chud's skull. That's
how he gets the movements down so perfectly. It's [__]
up.
Queman wants to get on the uh the son side or whatever side that
I don't. Okay, but realistically probably what happens I'll just
I'll explain it to you guys because you don't need a conspiracy
to explain it. Probably what happens is Quimman argues a lot
uh of his points on his stream obviously and then in spicy chat
two places that Chud is in a lot obviously he probably hears
those arguments and then if he thinks those arguments are decent
he just says oh that's like a good argument I what where's the
conspiracy really really really big problem happening here really
bad things happening here this is really terrible like I yeah
that's that's literally what it is someone someone makes a good
argument and you agree This is awful. We need to stop this
That's
Yeah, that's literally I Yeah, it's just very confusing that
people don't see that. That's obviously what's happening. But
I don't know what what he's trying to do, but that's what he
wants. Judge doesn't have the balls. But in order to do that,
you got to you got to you got to bring Nick down a peg and he's
balancing. And we'll show the balancing act in a second. Let
me get Willie sent me this video. This is really good. Disgusting
balancing act, dude. How that works. Has Willie Mack ever received
any funding or payment from Destiny, Dan Haltman, or anyone else
associated with Oh, so the guy the guy is accusing him of being
compromised and Chud will dismiss it. Liberal studios, that's
Destiny's media company. Not a single dollar. This is [__]
stupid, man. Like this is the problem is like there is a point
to be made there, but these like, you know, these videos go overboard
and go to these kind of like conspiracies that there's money
changing hands and stuff like that.
There's not money changing hands. It's more much simpler than
that. But what you want about money changing hands? That's ridiculous.
But yes, there is. You're on to something. But you're going,
"What? What are you up to?" It's the same [__] [__]
over and over again. He's on both sides of every issue. I don't
know how anybody guys can listen to him other than maybe he's
entertaining or funny because there's a point to be made there
and we're going to see this a lot because this goes to the heart
of both Weman and Chud. They don't criticize. They attack your
credibility. And that's a credibility attack. Look, if you say
there's a point to be made there, you simply maybe he doesn't
want to cause drama, like the excuse he gave for Nick. You simply
say that point, but he doesn't do that. That's what I can't stand
about him. I went I made a statement that a lot of people that
were demanding that um uh it was at the time of Dr. Disrespect
uh we we all should condemn him before all the facts were out
and he definitely deserved being um uh condemned. I said it's
just fascist behavior. Chud asked me to come on and then I got
cornered by Queman, which as we well know now, Chud is well aware
that that Queman's bad faith. Oh, no, no, no, no. He's aware
that he's like a hateful psychopath, not that he's bad faith.
No, no, no, no. Be correct, Tommy. That's true. That's annoying.
He knew that. He totally knew that you might get like carved
up live on that stream. But he didn't think it was going to be
bad faith. You let you sink or swim on your own. That's all.
Adam fed his dog for like months and he let him.
I'm sorry. That's I That's how I see it at least. Um which is
fine. I know. Listen, when I when I asked people if they want
to talk to Quean, I'm pretty honest about it. Okay, this this
is going to be rough. I was charged with this guy. This is a
50-year-old man saying he couldn't agree to talk to me. He wasn't
he wasn't able to exert his agency in talking to me. He was he
was
He was told, "This guy's highly critical of you. He has harsh
words for you. Do you want to 50-y old man? He's that woman on
the phone with Louis CK when Louis CK is jerking off and he's
just like, I can't I don't know what to do. He's ruining my life.
He's ruining my stream, brother. There's a red button on Discord.
The little phone disconnect. Hit the disconnect button, brother.
You're fine. You'll be okay. Let me know when you're asked. It's
not that. You don't have to talk to me when I'm asking to call
in. You if you're like if you literally can't take it and you're
going to crash out for it about it for the next year, then just
maybe say no. Queen ruined my hopes and dreams when he dropped
off on that phone call with me. When Queman called Nick a manchild,
he took it. You know, Nick is a W. Nick Lee, man. He took the
Queenman conversation really good. Wait, Nick did take that like
a like a He didn't even stop. He just kept fighting with his
wife. He changed zero behaviors and now his wife is totally subdued.
I mean, he kind of just won in every possible dimension, didn't
he? Tough to say.
It's It's up, but don't see him crying. Jesus. No, you don't.
Well, unless his wife, you know, sticks her arm out vaguely in
his direction. But yeah, not over not over the Queenman insults.
Definitely not. He immediately went to the little definition
trick. He asked me the definition of fascism. Kids, don't fall.
Yeah, this is just not I didn't ask him the definition of fascism.
I asked him what he meant when he was calling people fascist.
Your definition of fascism so I know he's going to harp on this.
I'm doing like dictionary games with him. It's not a dictionary
game. It's asking you what you're saying. It's like I'm not trying
to check it against the Google definition. In fact, he tells
me in the debate at one point he says, "Oh, won't you Google
it?" I'm like, well, googling it, I'm going to find fascism is
an ultra nationalist farright dictatorial form of government.
Like, that's what it's going to say. And that's obviously not
what you're saying. So, it's just me playing playing the dictionary.
No, I'm saying you're telling me to Google it, but the Google
thing is not what you're saying. Don't remember that cuz Aiden
said it. Aiden Ross. I wish I wish so badly that you would have
just gone, "Okay, are you cool with using the the Google definition
and just like Googled it and started using that and then making
him actually go ahead and say why it wasn't correct?" Cuz I don't
know. Like I I feel like when you say that's obviously not what
you want, I don't know. Somehow that Do you find that works?
I'm getting a meta convers. It's fine. I don't know. In my head
I'm like maybe there's a way to not put him so on defense, but
I'm sure he was already on defense anyway. Anyway,
definition questions. since he was throwing his guard up. It
it was just it was totally he like literally the moment I started
questioning him. It was he started digging his heels in the sand
and just not want
you give any other definition. It's bad. You don't know what
you're talking about. You fell for the red herring and you're
talking about that. This is something that Destiny does all the
time. So if you listen back, I refuse to do it and I stuck by
my guns. And then his Cleman's brilliant response was then why
isn't it fascist? Because it's apparent. Brilliant. Brilliant,
brilliant, brilliant stuff. So, it's just you have to agree with
me. You have to agree with me no matter what. What I'm arguing
that it's fascist, but I want you to argue why it's not fascist.
Go ahead. Go ahead. Go ahead. Go ahead. I just say, did you misspeak
and say destiny for Destiny? No. No. Did I miss? Okay. Let me
explain. Let me say you said I'll explain this again. I'll explain
this again. I made a statement that people are demanding we we
toss this guy under the bus. This this Dr. disrespect by who
eventually deserved to be tossed under the bust bus um were just
acting like a bunch of fascists and Que got on with me and said
that's an outrageous thing to say. His response for that was
not exactly how it went. I don't even remember how it went to
be honest with you. I'm just hoping this guy gets back to talking
about Chud.
I don't know why I don't know why he'd go after Chud in the first
place if he's just this mad at you that he's got to rant about
you instead of actually talking about the issue. Well, you'll
see you'll see his grand his grand thesis soon, Jay Sto. All
right. will be revealed. I don't even dude I wasn't even like
I didn't even hide from these people the fact that like you didn't
well maybe you did by being like reasonable in conversations.
I feel like I told whenever I talked to Tom or whenever I was
like, "Dude, you guys know you have like some around you that
Queen hates, right?" And like he's gonna like totally kill and
I said this in private at least a half dozen times to Doro. I
mean, it's not good. Like, what do you mean? What the I say,
yeah, we we talk about like taking people out or whatever. So,
you can't actually do that. They can only do that to themselves
after like a little bit of pressing, right? It's just like how
do you handle it? realistically impressed over something you're
wrong about on the internet then I mean you shouldn't have made
it in the first place frankly. Yeah sir Kico um what that actually
means is you andor Stylo I feel like it's probably a lot of Stylo
too have watched these people for like five plus years and you've
just like built up a list of things you get really annoyed about
by what what they when they do it or things they've the way they've
covered in the past and you're like I if I ever get a conversation
I'm going to bring all these things up. I'm going to bring up
exactly why I don't like them. That's what I mean. I don't think
I've even done that with any of them, have I? I don't think there's
even it's always been something present. I feel like ultimately
like the slasher stuff wasn't really present, but the reason
it came up is cuz Tommy C was leaning on that uh in regards to
why he thought it was like this huge leftwing conspiracy to take
out Dr. Disrespect. He was like leaning on the way they all covered
up for Slasher, but that wasn't there was nothing to cover up
for. It was just like a delegation and they disregarded it cuz
it was um that that was the key point there. that was about a
present issue that was about the look disrespect stuff really.
So there I don't think there's ever been a time where it's just
I just go back and it's like here's the thing you did 5 years
ago that me and Stylo went and looked at that we're going to
totally own you with no it's I don't think it's ever been that.
Um so it would be both. It would be like building up a set of
patterns that you dislike and it I I would say it absolutely
you know you know more about the person you know what weak points
to press on I guess. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. But yeah, you're probably right that it wouldn't
be it's not like you're going to go and bring it because you
kind of look like a like an absurler when you do that, right?
If you just bring something up from like four years ago that
sucks. Yeah. Just constantly ham overhead
that they're not fascist. His response was to do the definition
trick. And it's just a red herring fallacy. After the whole thing
was done, Chud went on to say this. Well, Tommy doesn't know
any abundantly clear. What is this? Stop pausing. Kenny, what
is a red herring fallacy? I I don't know. What's the red herring
fallacy? I don't know. I You're my fallacy guy. What is the red
herring fallacy? If I Google that, will that be a thing? I feel
like that's not a thing, but red herring fallacy. Oh, it is logical
fallacy where someone introduced an irrelevant topic or argument
to divert attention from the actual issue
discussed. Um, okay. So if he thought if you pre if you just
a priori define queen as bad faith and any question he asks you
about your meaning is done in bad faith then yeah that was probably
a red herring fallacy is right that it might be fascist demanding
people condemn before we all have the evidence it's the same
[__] here he does it all the time I didn't win two
years in a row sir stand it I can't stand it because if you want
to call it a sneak disc talking out by both sides your mouth
just being dubious, dishonest. I mean, call it what you will.
This is why I can't stand him. 100%. That's the perfect example.
And I bet you could find a million examples of that. I know you
can find it in this video that I'm about to show you. Why won't
you talk about Why won't you Why Why didn't you call him? You
guys were buds, right? Yeah. Why wouldn't I call him? That's
why I didn't call him. It's this little uh It's this little thing
right there. Now, forget the the thumbnail and the title because
the trap is there. Oh, you can't handle the bands and all that
stuff. Here's what I want you to do. Click in this video on your
own time. Pretend he's talking about you. And then ask yourself,
do you want to talk with that guy? Do you want to hash it out
with that guy? Or does he not like you? So, I got the Bobax leak.
That's shady. I got the Willie Mack thing. That's shady. I got
that. So, does this guy realize the Ch says about me or you?
Like, it's the idea that Oh.
straight up hurtful towards me. It's reallyed up, dude. I watch
I used to watch stream all the time and now I just would have
like tears. It's Tommy is mad that Chud is treating him the way
you would treat like basically anyone else. If anyone else uploaded
a video crying about how I've got no internet cuz I bought a
house where there's no internet even though I'm even though I'm
a live streamer and you know it's all I need money. Like if anyone
else did this we marked into the ground. Jud went easy on Tommy
in that in that reaction.
Um, and has made like a few comments digging at him or like called
Nick Dioro with Ethan Klein rider. Bro, that doesn't even scratch
the surface of Chud said about literally anyone else. Like, yeah,
Tommy doesn't remember the failed streamer industrial complex.
Uh, bro, uh, Chud watched like a interview and just talk about
every 5 minutes for like an hour straight. Yeah, like was actually
this guy is so boring. It's like totally waste of space. Worthless
straight like just going crazy.
He says the same about Aiden, too. Goes crazy about Aiden a lot.
Well, I said I spoke on one time make a video like nobody's going
to watch your channel, you know. Nice.
What? People watch your channel. Yeah, they do. Yeah, though.
Um, but like what is it? I think I talked to Chud once in DMs
and he was just like, "Hey, how's it going? You like doing good
financially?" He's like, "Uh, I don't know if you noticed, but
like sometimes in the spring like viewers dip and like things
could be tough, so I just try to hold on if you're having trouble."
I wasn't having trouble, but I was just like, "Oh, he like reached
out. I was just like being kind." So, like, that's Sorry to leak
that for all of you guys. He's actually like kind of a nice person
sometimes. He was taking he was taking a dig at you. He was saying,
"Oh, I see a viewership's down." He might have been. I don't
know. But I'm I'm just saying I thought he was being nice. I
didn't I didn't pick that up, but maybe he was. Get Chud to Alog
out of streaming, dude. Which is cool. I don't know why you guys
see this. This is where it starts. Is going to be the next is
going to go and hang out with Nicholas Dorio. Darra is already
making uh overtures. Okay. You guys don't see the board, which
is cool.
too dumb to know. No, I'm not too dumb to know when I'm being
insulted. I'm pretty good at that. New pirate software Google
dro Google doc dropped. Well, that's going to be good for Wednesday.
I'm going to be psyched to do that. I'm going to love covering
the pirate software stuff. Yeah. Also, is that
the the website for um the website for the pirate software stuff
sucks to be honest with you. Or at least the way they formatted
the logs kind of annoying. Anyway, we're good. Are you guys acting
this treating this guy like he's Dutch? What is the name? I missed
the meme. The cars. Why? Why did you do this? Somebody explain
it. Spiritually
Oh, spiritually Indian. Unfortunately. Yeah, things are stacking
up where I don't I think I'm allowed not to trust him. And yeah,
I didn't call him. By the way, by the way, I talked to Chud,
played video games with him pretty much throughout the month
of December. I think two streams or or one night we did it alone
and there was a stream or something like that. I haven't heard
a word. So, that kind of goes both way. Maybe you should call
Mo. Why don't you call me? I might I might have thought Mo maybe
it was an isolated incident but I no longer think this is isolated
incidents. When the New Year stream happened I was like yeah
there's something there. This guy's incredibly dishonest. You
want to know what Trump actually thinks? Are are you Oh, I see.
Has it been that a lot of those guys have like kind of stopped?
No, that's can't be it. Cuz I I could almost see that New Year
stream like putting them off from interacting with Chud, but
I could have sworn they kept interacting with Chud throughout
like January cuz the Mudahar stuff would have happened. Would
that not have happened after
before? It was before. Okay. Okay. All right. Bad faith. I mean,
Willie came on my stream. I feel like I'm associated enough.
So that that would be weird. Um Oh, yeah. Sure. Then I don't
know what else. I feel like Nick's been in his chat a lot. Nick's
seemingly been fine with him. Nick. Nick was fine with him. Yeah.
No, Nick was totally fine with him after that. Yeah. Very nice.
Ben sitting. Listen to Queman. He'll tell you, but he's got nothing
to lose and shut does. And that's what it really comes down to.
He doesn't understand. I don't know. I don't know if he doesn't
just bad faith. You could criticize Nick. The Here's the funny
thing. Do you see this particular um uh um picture of me right
when I was moving? This is clip from a video where I was criticizing
Ethan Klein. I never started drama with Nick. Nobody ran to Nick
and said, "He's attacking you."
when he said, "I'm talking about you, Nicholas Dioro, and then
shoehorning something somebody else said like Stardust." Yeah,
I think he did it on purpose. I'm no longer um being generous.
I think he did it on purpose. Wait, who sent Who would have sent
Chud that clip of Stardust? There would have been
Well, no, no, no. What What happened was Chud mentioned the clip
already. Ch had mentioned, he'd obviously seen it in the wild
or on my stream before or something and he mentioned the clip
in that rant and then I sent it to him and I I sent him the Stardust
clip and I was in chat being like produced that segment of him
Nicholas Doro is what you're saying. Exactly. Yeah. Yeah. I ghost
wrote the the script for Nicholas. I said, "Yeah, call him an
Ethan Klein sucker next." Yeah. Great.
Uh, sorry. I'm just I'm trying to help you, Tommy. Okay, you're
in trouble. I'm just trying to help. I'm just trying to even
the odds for you. Okay, buddy. Just remember, if you somehow
come out on top of this, okay, this is like me buying a lottery
ticket right now. You somehow come out on top of this and take
Chud and Queen down simultaneously, I'm going to want some collabs.
All right, I'm going to want a couple hosts if I'm ever back
on YouTube. I'm just saying it explicitly, okay? I can't be snaky
if I'm saying it all out in the open, right? We're good. We're
good. So, why would you talk to them? I don't understand that
at all. I wouldn't talk to somebody like that. And you know,
you could always hide. You look, say something outrageous, attack
people's credibility, and say, "Hey, you can't handle the bands.
You can't handle the banter." It's just an endless circle of
being dishonest. It's endless circle of of bear faith. That's
all it was. So that's why this milktoast thing, fence sitter
thing is really just look, all this stuff's all this stuff is
run by money. Don't even your favorite YouTubers, even the good
ones, everything, every decision is made on topics to cover is
about money. I'm not above it and nobody else is. It's easy.
It's very easy to Is he just admitting that yeah, Nicholas is
riding uh Ethan Klein right now? This all all of these decisions
are made saying he's saying Ch is purely financially motivated,
but obviously Nick is totally pure innocent and suggesting that
any of his coverage might be motivated by the increased financial
incentive is is disgusting. You shouldn't attack his credibility
like that because that's Nick. Hold on. Hold on. No, no, no.
You shouldn't attack his his his uh his credibility because they're
friends, not because it's like pure or I haven't heard him say
it's pure. I've heard him say that even the good YouTubers are
financially motivated. Sure. Sure. I'm being sarcastic. That's
okay. Wait, hold on. Who's being sarcastic? He is.
Oh, well, no. I can tell. Sorry, sorry, sorry. I can tell he's
overplaying it, but I I thought you were making a genuine like
uh the point is that he seems to only apply this to Ch. Like
he's never he's like saying Ch is a snake that you know he's
doing this for money, but to suggest that Nick is doing it for
money would be like way over the
Um, I think there I'm just guessing that there might be ways
to do that without them off, but um that this would be a way
that it's like even though it's accurate and it's like totally
consistent with what Chud does in public and who he's always
been that like they would say that's bad. Like if you're in the
cabal, you don't do that. Which I think is part of the problem.
I think everybody sees it as a problem that that attitude exists.
Just some people think it's like the other side that needs to
come to their thinking, right? or sorry that's the the disagreement
is like everybody agrees that it's a problem but um obviously
I think they are like yeah you shouldn't you know if you're doing
collabs with these people if they invite you on their new year
stream you don't press them what are you doing sit there and
you be nice you don't call Nicholas out on your stream you don't
say Nicholas Doro I'm talking to you say like oh well many people
have you know kind of it's just like so it's like comedic it's
like you're really you're mad about that's right Nicholas Doro
I'm calling you out anything you think you're this is what we're
mad about. This is what we're upset about right now.
Uh yeah, and again, I can't I can't like actually put into words
just how much that opinion is almost certainly just something
he saw somebody say in a chat and he thought it was funny or
saw somebody say another stream and he thought it was funny and
he just kind of leans into it without really having that opinion
like super solidly himself. Like he he probably doesn't think
Nicholas is just a total reperbait who's only chasing money and
has no morals, right?
like I'm not I'm not saying that. I've l not been saying that
the whole time. I've not se total reprimate his chasing morals.
I've said that I think yeah it's totally possible this playing
a role in his bias, but I have seen him just sort of it feel
it feels like he does just look the other way with some content
creators when the going's good and he thinks they're awesome.
I thought he did that with Destiny for a long time when he would
have disavowed someone who did the same actions that he did.
And I feel like he's doing that with Ethan right now. I also
I think that is that is a thing I've seen from Nick that I think
is happening that I I've laid out many times, you know, where
I think that's happening on this issue. Nick doesn't want to
talk about it. That's fine, you know, but what? So, no one can
mention that that's a thing or that that's maybe like a reasonable
argument ever because well, Nick Dior is nice to them. Like,
what is Tommy's point, you know? Yeah. act like everybody else
is selling out when you you're not depending on the money. Ch's
depending on the money. So, believe me, I've done this long enough
to realize, yeah, you're going to avoid this, you're going to
avoid that. But if Chud wanted to criticize Nick or not even
criticize Nick, criticize Nick's arguments. But they don't know
that. They don't know the difference between No, I'm not going
to. They do know the difference. Who am I kidding here? Attacking
your credibility is the Bance to them. attack your credibility
is
um is is is criticism. What's the matter? You can't take criticism.
You're taking my credibility on my argument. That's what they
do over and over again. Quean does it. His minions do it. They
all do it. Chud does it except he's a mean girl about it and
does sneak disc when you call Queman would never totally disingenuously
and dishonestly and knowingly lie about somebody just to with
them ever. He would never do that. Okay. ever. I can't think
of a single What could this guy be saying about? What could this
guy I just saw you say I saw a clip of you saying, "Oh, I lie
about that."
I just saw a clip of you saying you lied about it. I was like,
"Oh, that was a nice thing to do." Like as a friend to just be
like, "Oh, yeah, I do lie about that just to with him." I was
like, "Oh, that's nice of him. That was nice of him to do." See,
even Queen is nice sometimes. Can I get that clip? Can someone
send me that clip of him being nice?
Yeah, but like we can't let this go. We can't let this go without
this being shown to everybody. Someone got that clip? You not
like this, but I actually actually clipped in the moment uh saying
that. I actually didn't even think I was like pretend I shouldn't
have even said that. I shouldn't have even given the example,
but I was just like sort of talking through it. Yeah, I just
said that. I wouldn't have actually seeded that ground if that
was a thoughtout decision. He was just like, you know what? This
guy's actually a good friend and I'm gonna I'm gonna go ahead
and even though I'd usually with somebody on this, I'm gonna
do this. He was looking the other way. Okay. Well, not really
because he made it up in the first Well,
it's not really made up like Destiny kind of made it up, I guess.
But Queman had contrary.
Good times. Good times. Anyway, we can call him out. You play
stupid or says you're soft and then letman do the rest. That's
probably I am X fat. That is literally what I have always said.
Missy Elliot, tell me what it is. How coordinated is I don't
know. I don't care. If you want to know what Chud thinks, talk
to Quean.
Queen thinks Nick the Oreo is a sellout. All those guys think
he's a sellout and he's um unfairly praising Ethan Klein instead
of attacking the praises. He says
the best part is is I talk to Queen more than Chud does. So actually
if you want to know what Chud thinks, you should probably talk
to me.
Your ego is fat. Shut up, Cherry. Rider, you say he's a sweeper
and don't provide any explanation why that's the case. Just like
that Willie clip I showed you. It's just that simple. So, can
anybody really believe that there's actually no alignment here?
I mean, Hassan pulls this [__] all the time. Hey,
listen. I can't control this guy. I disagree with him, but he
does a great job. But here, if you thought he was
That's me. That's true. Yeah, that's true. That's true. I don't
know if Cleman has the uh the coahones to go into a video game
person. I don't think he could do it. Sure. I literally wouldn't
do I could not take it that far. He couldn't pull up GTA 6.
This is
disrespect in Florida. He would never do it. He would never go
to Miami Beach directly in GTA 6. Miami chase down. He would
never do it. He doesn't have He doesn't have it. Pull the trigger.
Bad faith. You wouldn't have put him on your show. You wouldn't
have platform him. Chad's got no problem with Gman being bad
faith. None whatsoever. None at all. Stream snipe him at Rust.
Can you stream site Dan and Rust? I feel like I feel like Dan
like plays that game religiously. That would be that would be
awesome actually.
That'd be really funny. But like those people literally all like
know like we need to get together like a mart brigade like clan
and like
October 7th, 2025.
Oh, that's dark. That's dark. That's dark. That's grossly offensive.
Dish a vow. Very antiatic of you. He just will continue to do
this whole thing over and over and over again and then play stupid.
That's the idea. The idea that he doesn't associate with Queenman
is comically stupid.
It's a com that would be comically stupid. Who's ever said that?
That would be comically stupid. Yeah, that would be so comically
stupid. Comically stupid things to correct. If anyone ever said
that, that would be comically stupid.
Comical lie. And I honestly think they probably they more than
likely just sit around and say, "Well, if they do say this, we'll
say that because you could predict what they're going to say.
No problem whatsoever." My last thing, and then I actually we'll
move on. I literally don't know when the last time I've been
in a private call with each other is. The idea that we sit around
trying to get on message together is just so [__]
stupid. Might have been in my Discord, honestly. I think it would
have been ago like few months ago. Yeah. When the Destiny stuff
first dropped, probably. Yeah, this I want this slot. This one's
way way better. Okay, last thing I got to say. I'm going to mention
Aiden real quick. Aiden made a comment. He said that I come from
a community
um that if we criticize each other, it's just it's over. It's
done. I don't know. Anybody watched me long enough, I could take
a joke. I can get my balls busted. I can do all those things.
It's just not true. I can be criticized. That's not true. What
they do is called credibility attacks. and the credibility tax,
sweeper, rider, all those things and say you can't handle the
bats. It's bad faith. It's dishonest. It's what Chud's doing.
Okay, if that's true, oh, that's this is why they win, right?
You're bad faith. You attack my credibility. I can never speak
to you because you're bad faith and you attack my you like literally
by definition I can never discuss this with you ever. Right?
So they they've already built in the responses. They just have
to ignore you. It's like I don't know at this point you'd like
have to actually want to argue with these people, right? Like
I you could easily just publish a video saying what your criticisms
are and have them like respond to that, right? That's probably
where you'd have to go. But then you're literally just trying
to fight with them and it's like I don't want to fight with you.
We just talk through this, right? All right. It's what he's doing
on the surface. That's what it that's what it is. Oh, there is
another thing I almost forgot. Uh Chud mentioned and uh this
was and this is an example of just being deliberately dishonest
with context. Chud said, "Why don't you call me a if just come
out and say it? I didn't call you one. I didn't say you're a
groomer. Here's what I said. And I'm not going to pretend to
teach you right now. I'm just going to teach the audience. I'm
not going to pretend you didn't understand what I said. I said
you got catfished and that's up." And people look the other way.
The context being even if you're innocent like Chud was of the
whole thing, it was he was actually set up by some freaking minor.
There's no doubt about it.
The idea the other way is that you're not innocent. Yeah. Exactly
right. Yeah. It's the clearly implied like it's fine if he wants
to clarify it here and say he misspoke, but it act like everyone's
being in bad faith for reading your statement the literal way
you said it. It it was like very like everyone read it that way.
Everybody thought you were innocent and we all looked the other
way. Yeah, that makes no sense. [__] what the are
you doing? Okay, whatever. I've stuck up for Zapai and other
people. I have initially stuck up for zero until he was irrepented.
I have a history of sticking up for people that he looked the
other way for zero. Make massive mistakes. But on YouTube and
he knows this nine times out of 10 that's lights out. Nine times
out of 10, lights out. You're finished. It doesn't matter the
context, right? the context he want wouldn't afford me. So this
whole thing, why don't you just call me a then? Uh, if Chad had
met up with that person in real life, that would have been lights
out 100%. If Chad had met up with that person in real life and
had happened, yeah, he would have been done. Uh DMs. I feel like
somebody lies to you. You've only had DMs. You've not sent Well,
I actually don't know if photos were sent there, but I I kind
of assume not because I assume that would be if photos were sent
like LWD or nude photographs were sent by this person. I assume
the attack wouldn't be Chud like is a or whatever. It would be
that Chud
uh was in possession of CP, right? So, I assume there wasn't
any any there cuz I don't hear that allegation ever. Yeah. What
type of were they saying to each other? There's no excuse for
kids by law. Um I it was like generally like flirty, right? Sorry.
Go ahead, Quayman. You said there were no video though. No photos,
no videos. They weren't surprised the videos exchange. No. Okay.
Um and then I mean the person was pretending to be 18 or 19 when
they were 17 or something, right? Yeah.
Yeah. So I don't know. Would the law in the UK be that like oh
it's they're under 18? I don't think so. For texting for LWD
conversations have to be what it what it is to people, right?
I think it's all just 16. I think. I'm not sure. I just Yeah.
Well, Miss Elliot, you have to put both together that the kid
lied and that it never went to a place where like Chud not verifying
it or I don't think there were DMs that like Yeah, exactly. There
wasn't really an for the level of conversation this was at. someone,
you know, like reporting that they're of age is is like enough
for that level of conversation. I feel like if they were like
trading photos or some [__] yeah, you'd expect a
little bit more rigor, especially from someone you on Discord,
but for the level of conversation they're engaging in, you you
wouldn't usually expect someone to to do that, especially when
Chud was like, you know, it's not like he was a he was a big
streamer. He was some or maybe some retail on Discord at that
point. Sorry, Deepama. Why would he be the treasurer? Why couldn't
he just make
Why would he be in charge of the money? Why would a Subway have
a treasurer? I feel this guy. Um, okay. And yeah, anyway, that
that would be my I again, I haven't actually looked deeply into
the Chud thing. Without images, you can pretend to be any age.
Yeah, but like this person is this person's pretending to be
a year older than they are. That's something that you can do
very conceivably. Anybody can do to pretend to be a year older
than you are. Basically, anybody above the age of five can do
that, right? Convincingly. So to me to me it's like how likely
are they to be able to figure out good one accelerate how likely
are they to be able to figure out that there's something bad
happening there right? Yeah.
Unfortunately for Chud there was a couple comments about I shouldn't
engage with this. You're very young because of the 18 age.
Not good look. I can see how that could have potentially gone
against him. Okay. Those those comments not great. I didn't even
suggest it. I said you were a catfish. I said it was up and all
the people that you're trying to snake, Willie, Tom, me. Well,
I guess it in to some extent. Boaxs um were nice to you and looked
the other way. Instead of saying, "Well, look, I that guy might
be innocent. I won't I can't but I can't be associated with him."
They gave you a chance. They gave you a chance because of Nick's
good will. That's what they did. But you're trying to snake him.
So, back to Aiden. Ben says that that we come from a community
who criticize each other. the friendship's over and what have
you. First of all, that's not
if Nicholas just went live, watched that clip and said, "Well,
at least I'm batting somebody of age and like literally just
continue his coverage like that day, the whole thing is nothing
and there's just no
concerns." Yeah. Literally, literally that's the response and
then we all move on with our lives. I don't know. True. It's
the credibility attacks. That's what it is. I mean, Queenman
has no problem or no compunction. He does not give a if something's
true, if it's out of context, it's whatever sticks. Willie said
something interesting about him that he respects a lot more.
That's true. One example of me of me just being like totally
dishonest that isn't like some joke. Like that's a little different.
That's not That doesn't really apply to this to be honest. I
It can't even be sneaky because you literally told me you were
going to do it in the conversation. It like it can't be sneaky
by definition. You literally were like, "Oh, I'm still going
to call you fat cuz it's funnier now.
So I like it's not snaky. It could be it's being an but it's
not snaky. I literally just don't know like one example. I would
love to give you one example where I'm being dishonest that isn't
just oh queen was really mean to me at debate like okay I think
he has different rules anyway. Yeah sure. Again yes this is um
you can just run unfortunately you know we're not huge Destiny
fans here. I don't know if anybody realizes that, but you can
just run the whole like Vosch section of the Keles manifesto
for this, right? Where it's like, okay, you're going to say that
I'm doing this and I'm doing that. Show a clip. Show a clip.
Show me where you're pulling this from. Show me any evidence,
any positive evidence other than you just like making this up.
Please go ahead.
And again, it it's just his characterizations of what happened
and not clips of what happened. It's goofy. It's goofy. Anytime
somebody's doing that, right, if they can't pull up clips and
just react and say what's going on, it's it's just evidence that
they know they're wrong, right? More because he's just trying
to make YouTube work. And we've seen it before with these anti-
community communities, right? It's just whatever sticks. We saw
all the way back in the day, which they remind me the most of,
um, but Lamer, uh, the Blood Sports thing with Medicare and Tonka
and all those guys, but they
I think we won. We get to be Medicica and Tonka. That's awesome.
destroy each other. The most recent version was being medic was
awesome if you're not having cancer and you're having your spine
erased. I don't know. I old gym clips. Love Jim. Okay. But anyway,
community and they they ate each other as well. They he ate himself
and then god that guy ate they they ate each other and they ate
and then he ate himself.
Ah, I'm going to make another I'm going to make another claim
that's going to make upset. 2016 Trump was awesome. Okay, that
guy was funny as that guy. That guy I excuse people who voted
for that guy. Okay. You voted for 2024 Trump, you're unsavable.
Okay. You voted for 2016 Trump. I can forgive you. All right.
Why that made me mad? It's on. Uh cuz I feel like probably the
reason you dislike those guys cuz they're in the tank for Trump.
No. Something else you really dislike about them.
Well, I like Trump in the first run. You know, I was like a Sargon
when I was a teenager. So,
okay. All these anti- community communities, they go away. They
get really freaking hot and then they fizzle out because eventually
the line gets boring. These comm What is he he's like he's like
preemptively saying these guys are going to be really successful
with like this line of content. Totally. Which at least somebody
is faith. But I but I don't even He's like dude it's not even
successful. It's like I don't think there's anybody unless you
want to say Chud is anti somebody. There's nobody even getting
a thousand viewers doing this kind of content. Really, I don't
even know if I'd say it's a kind of content. It's like a group
of people who get like I don't know between 100 and 500 viewers,
whatever. Eventually, the bad faith gets boring. Ku women doesn't
have any reputation for being good faith. Most of the people
watch two of two countries who are their own biggest trading
partners. You can't do that unilaterally as citizens. Okay, you
you are actually you're basically the Houthies. That was the
Canadian Houthies right there. Okay. and skulls should have been
cracked with those people. They don't like the fact that I'm
so so-called conflating them. The problem is I don't think it's
an accident. I don't think I'm crazy here when he puts him on,
lets him say a [__] but I disagree with that. It's
the same he did with Willie. It's the same [__] he
does with everybody else. You know, that's really interesting.
But um I got to distance myself. Yeah. I'm calling [__]
And that's it. That's all.
There's almost I'll say there's almost a criticism there. Okay.
That Chud often does the like, oh, I don't know about this guy
at all. When he like probably doesn't think the person's and
probably like he does it with you, right? He probably doesn't
think you're he brings you on. He'll say like, "Oh, I disavow
like this and that." And he might not even really disavow it
that hard. But I'd say I feel like 90 off the top of my off the
dome. Okay. 90% of the time I can tell more or less what his
position is. very transparent, right? Like when he's just laughing
it up and going, "I totally disavow that. That's a disgusting
comment." Yeah. He's not he's not being a snake. He's literally
telling you that that's funny, but it's like improper to say
it. I don't know. I don't feel like I can't read the guy at all.
Cuz I think that's what Tommy's doing is he's trying to say like,
"Oh, well, Tre will go I totally disavow that guy. I don't know
what that guy's talking about. I don't I don't know what he's
on about. He's a and he's annoying. I'm Ch's Australian." It
feels like what he's suggesting is like basically it is obviously
there's obviously truth to this. It's like Chud knows I disagree
with a lot of these people in a very harsh way and likes having
that around cuz it creates more content and more disagreement.
But that's not like someone having a knife to your throat like
Tommy seems to think it is. It's just like that's content. Like
talking about and disagreeing about Yeah. That's what people
want to see. You're doing commentary content where the point
is to voice your opinions. Yeah. People want to see those opinions
clash a lot of the time. That's part that's part of the fun.
So to suggest it's like something like malicious or nefarious
is just like so it's like no, they should this is the point of
the content and that's as it's you know that that's how it's
presented. I'm trying to think of like how there's some way we
could compare this and like make it make more sense cuz I I understand
that's like the point of the content spiritually that it's criticism,
but I do think at some point people shift from just being like,
"Oh, we're we're just trying to find the the like overt truth
and now we're just trying to make money, right?" Like like it
it switches over. And I don't think like I don't think that's
all it is. Like I
think there is some point where it's like okay I don't want my
ideas to clash because yeah my ideas aren't perfect but they're
like the closest to the best and I think like somebody could
be skilled enough to make me look really bad on the downsides
of my points. Sure. But then what's the problem with that? That
it's going to lose them a bunch of money interacting with you.
I don't think it will though. I don't see that looking bad really
lose you that much money. Um yeah maybe it's just like ego the
only thing it can be. I don't I don't feel
I do think there's a lot of people in this space who do you think
there aren't a lot of people in this space who watch Nicholas
cuz he's kind of like Destiny in a way like as in like my beats
these I I like this guy cuz he's the person who like hits the
I hate the hardest. Right. Maybe. But I don't think that gets
completely shaken by disagreeing with someone or looking bad
in conversation. But if you look and you're not like if you if
you suddenly if specifically the criticism is of the that they're
hitting or the way he's making the criticism of Nick is the that
his criticism of the he's hitting is disingenuous. Then you're
you're literally attacking like the core thing to what's getting
him viewers right now. Right. Sure. But the criticism isn't necessarily
that it's disingenuous. The criticism is a specific points that
I disagree on. Now I do. I think there's like some level level
of maybe this disingenuity. I I don't know, man. Creeping in.
Yeah, sure. I don't know if that's a word. Yeah, I don't know
either, but but yeah, a level of that creeping in. Uh maybe possibly,
but that's not really what my criticism is. The criticism isn't
being disingenuous. The criticisms are specific points I've disagreed
on. I actually think that doesn't matter. the the the
the genuiness the how genuine the point is actually doesn't matter
and I shouldn't have even used that word it's that it's like
incorrect or it's not correct like at all like that basically
you're arguing that he is wrong on like one of his criticisms
and basically that's the thing people sign up to him for are
like those criticisms and so it's like um it's like if you signed
up or if you're following um I don't know like some online pastor
and they just got totally ass blasted okay a Christian
They are all Christians anyway, a pastor and he gets like ass
blasted by some Muslim guy in a debate. Like I think a lot of
these people like genuinely don't have internal monologues and
they will just be like, "Oh, I guess I should watch that other
guy." I think that could happen a decent amount. Now, is it just
for that to happen? Probably, right? If the person can't defend
their ideas or if they're just making bad arguments overall and
people are following them for those arguments, then probably
that should happen. I just don't really buy this. I'm going to
be real cuz I know I don't think anyone like you know Destiny
got the wiped on the JQ against Fentes. He lost that so bad.
I don't think really switched over. He got he got saved pretty
hard by that getting like totally off of YouTube on any big channel
and the only copy of it is his editing from August maybe. Right.
I think he kind of got lucky there. And same thing the other
one he lost was like another Ryan Dawson debate or something.
Right. Yeah. I don't think anyone changed from that either. I
should buy it. I just don't buy it. Yeah. I'm not sure honestly.
Um I know what your criticisms of Nick are and I've definitely
laughed at like certain positions he's taken, but I don't watch
enough of his content to really make like the same level of criticism.
Like it's just like the the Nazi sword thing, some of his the
some of the overreactions around like the skulls and stuff. It
just seemed like, oh, we're getting like kind of riled up into
a frenzy and thinking this is all like the worst possible thing
all the time automatically. Yeah. In the music theory blues debate.
I disagree. I don't think uh I don't think Why can't I think
of her name? She's in my Discord. Giana, whatever her name is.
Giana. I don't I don't think GA won that to be honest with you.
The one like and said that crazy too. Yeah, that one. That one.
That was it. You pass like a legendary
pass like a pretty goofy. Um pretty goofy. Yeah. No, I I actually
disagree with you, Deep. I think I don't care to defend him though.
[__] him. Whatever. Gianna won. I literally don't
even care. I think that was my opinion, but I'm not gonna argue
that. That you're right, Spudgun. I just don't I don't know.
I'm trying to think like I do think there's reason for Nick to
be like concerned or not want to have those arguments. I think
it's like rational, but it's not rational from like a principal
point of view. It's rational from like a probably the rational
argument against him engaging is that it would affect his bottom
line, right? Or like so it's not like a moral argument. I think
that upsets people.
I I'm probably just laying out what people already like people
are like, "Yeah, duh." But I don't know. I I don't necessarily
think it's like um totally immoral to protect how much money
you're making, especially if you think like broadly in like in
the broad strokes, you're probably not like harming anybody by
doing the content you're doing. Yeah. I just don't think it's
like that. I don't think Nick's sitting there thinking, "Oh,
I can't debate this cuz I'll lose money from debating it." I
don't think that's the case.
Wait, why is the donor just staying on screen? Because it's paused.
it's paused. That wasn't my dono. If you're going to sit there.
Wait, I didn't get a dono, did I? I heard a sound, but I thought
it was Kenny or Queen. Am I crazy? Does money justify lying?
No. But again, does Nick think Do you think Nick's lying outright?
There's like a there's like a a pretty smooth difficult to place
line between what you would say is like outright lying or even
what you would say is lying and what you would say is being hyperbolic,
He's worried about looking bad in front of H3. Maybe. Yeah. I'm
trying to think cuz like I I don't spend a ton of time thinking
about this stuff. So sometimes I just sit here and I have to
like I have like intuitions about how I feel about the Nick thing.
I intuitively feel like um I don't really think it's all that
bad or I I guess I I don't know if I'd do something different
in his shoes is probably what I should say.
We don't need to finish in 12 months, buddy. Uh yeah, but again
in a cult, bro. Okay. To pull the cult card once in a while.
Do you think Nick's in a cult?
Um, I think he's got a kind of like a cult follower mindset.
You know, he's perpetually a cult. He's a cult making. Maybe.
I definitely think this with aristocracy and like, oh, it's three
skulls for like the three kids he has or
I think a lot of it is just like praising strength really. You
know, there's like perceived strength. Ethan's owning the haters.
Destiny owned owned all these haters, owned all these lefties.
I felt it's just like a thing of perceived strength and latching
on to that a lot of the time.
Yeah. And I think we can we can continue on with this. I'm trying
to think of like um I probably need to sit down and think more
about like a holistic theory of why I think that works the
I think that does explain like that is the whole hitting the
harder, you know, hitting the person that hits the you hate the
hardest. That is a lot of it. A lot of people I think a lot of
people in my knowledge like that where they'll just gravitate
towards whoever's looking. Well, the thing is is usually what
they don't do and probably what this probably how Nick gets away,
right? Um cuz I know that this is I think I've said this to people,
but that's like why I would just go after Hassan, right? That's
literally I feel like I was Nick and Nick just had like a bigger
platform to do it with, right? And a more like disconnected platform
from other big influencers. So like I would just I don't have
to defend Destiny. I can just like [__] on Hassan,
right? And of course if you're just looking to [__]
on somebody. You can find like things to [__] on
and laugh at and make fun of. It's pretty easy. Hassan's not
exactly the the most what do you call it? Careful speaker. What
do you mean? Sometimes you might get it wrong. Sometimes you
might on someone and you on them because you think it's easy,
but you're actually saying something really silly in the process.
Uh that could be the case. I don't think so though cuz I was
very I was very careful about it especially when Santan started
talking about me. That was concerning. Um yeah, I never I never
went on the limbs that some of these people do. But I it's just
easier. Sorry. My my grand point there is you don't have to defend
the person. So you get away with not defending them. Like I didn't
have to defend Destiny. Just tack us on. Right. I I don't have
to defend Destiny. I could be like, "Oh yeah, whatever. Destiny
kind of sucks too." Right? But it's like without the Oh man.
It's like participating in an arena and you like you've built
up it's like you have a left arm and a right arm and your left
arm is like
gigachad like built and your right arm which is used to criticize
like the people you like is just totally withered and dead, right?
And then you you like show anybody that you see like that is
probably somebody you should be suspect of, right? That like
they have like these really well thoughtout criticisms. They
spend a ton of time criticizing certain people. They never criticize
like the other people they like at all. Right. It's just it's
probably not or the other people that I guess are allied with
them. It's probably like a totally systemic issue. I might be
just describing like um I think that's Yeah, I think that's just
like kind that is kind of natural to to just like if you're align
people, you spend less time you just spend less time focusing
on the things they did wrong. I don't think that's even like
necessarily a problem. Again, the thing that I always like say
is just be like engage honestly and accurately describe who the
people are that you're both aligning with and criticizing and
what they're doing. When people try to play this plausible deniability
game about weaponizing the ADL and what that means, that's insufferable.
If you're being honest, even if you're on Ethan's side, you can
look at and say like Dan loves the ADL. He's in the ADL's DMs
constantly. also in Ethan's DMs. He's in DMs with every single
person that's talking [__] on his son. Obviously,
we can draw not it's not even like a conspiracy at this point,
like especially theory at this point. It's just like you're watching
in real time. There is like one guy who's like the point of contact
for like everyone. Um and and he's admitting to using the ADL.
Uh so that it's not even like a theory at that point. You're
just like describing exactly what's going on. Now they got the
redact dev button on their on their show. It's like you're you're
describing exactly what's going on right in front of you. And
everyone's like, "What? What do you mean you're weaponizing the
AO?" It's like, "Okay, you're not being honest at this point.
You're just not being honest. You're you're like uh you're just
you are just playing defense for censorship campaigns or trying
to like play along with it. You get as far as you can without
being
Well, and or you're just and you don't understand that that censorship
like that that group getting more prestige, that group getting
more power is going to be used in a way that's for you in the
near future. Like they it's basically um they want Yeah, sorry.
It's it's basically the same point. They want censorship just
not on themselves. They don't they don't care. They don't they
don't see it or they refuse to acknowledge that it's going to
hit everyone by now. Enough people have pointed out though. Well,
I think um
I think the response to Chud being, "Dude, Ethan's never weaponized
the ADL. What are you talking about?"
I don't know.
Anyway, sir, we should finish this. Tommy, I can't take the bands.
Fine. I was going to stream for like 3 hours tonight and I'm
here on hour six now. If you're going to do what Queenman's little
crowd did and said, get this with the with the thing that I knew
uh I knew that Jud was a groomer and I let it go until it was
inconvenient for me. Oh, that's funny. And honestly, that's what
you said. That is the implication of what you said. Yeah. I think
Chud knew that it was going to be t if you say what is meant
to do about you saying that. Like you you did say that. I'm sorry.
If you want to take it back, that's fine. Everyone's f I don't
think anyone's going to be like, "No, Tommy absolutely meant
that. He didn't miswire himself or anything like that." Like,
take it back. Sure, whatever. But that is what you said. That
was the meaning of the word you said. You misspoke. It's fine.
to act like everyone's misconstruing you and treating you poorly.
You're so Yep.
Um, dude. Yeah, because honestly, if you I'm sorry, but if you
mean if you literally mean, well, we actually gave you a shot
despite your like, you know, we knew we knew your reputation
was was hurt for no reason, but we wouldn't have [__]
with you and we with you cuz Nick helped you, right? That's like
a totally different thing. That's not looking the other way.
I don't know. I don't see how you could Yeah, you make the clarification
now, but it's just not the same thing. Taken like that. I never
said that. I actually gave him the bed of the doubt. Catfished
and that's [__] up. So that's who you're dealing
with. That's That's your
I Man, do we have to go back and watch it again? Did you go back
and watch it again? I feel like the clip. I don't know if I have
the I don't know if I have the clip, so I'm just going to pull
the video probably. But here's the thing. I'm just going to look
for cap. Uh, up, I think, cuz I heard him say up. Oh, whoops.
Up. Okay, we're just going to have a trillion things here now.
Cool. We set them up. Hold on. Catfish. Catfish by a 17-year-old
boy. And everybody, including myself, looked the other way, thought
it was up, and gave you the best. A year ago, I couldn't believe
I was saying this. I was on the phone. This guy's the best guy.
I'm so I love his show. I love calling in. Do you ever see me
call in every That right there sounds a little closer. I'm wondering
what I heard before this. But I uh I wonder cuz he talks about
it again. I'm almost positive. Never. Never. Cuz I love it. And
then all of a sudden I get a donation and I'm a be they're entertaining
me being a pest and they're entertaining uh the whole slasher
thing which I don't particularly remember but and he did shut
it down. That's for our boys in the transcript. Well, a 17-year-old
boy catfish by a 17-year-old boy we saw already. Oh yeah. Well,
that's the clip. That's the time he speaks about. Go back. Very,
very good for you. Unbelievably
generous. Let's not forget that you got catfished by a 17-year-old
boy. And everybody, including myself, looked the other way, thought
it was up, and gave you the best. A year ago, I couldn't believe
I was saying this. I was on the phone. This guy's the best guy.
So, I love his I mean, look the other way. the obvious implications
that something bad happened, especially saying it's
Yeah, but I would sorry now that he's clarified. Okay. I think
the clarification is okay. I don't think anybody who read it
the other way is wrong. I think I think the more obvious cuz
it's what we all thought basically in unison was what he meant
was, "Oh, I looked the other way." But he says something else
here as another word. And everybody, including myself, looked
the other way, thought it was up and gave you the best. looked
the other way, thought it was up. So, that could go either way,
and then gave you the best. Doesn't mean I don't know. I can
see it. I can see it going either way now that he's clarified.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying. I can see that if you don't know
the implication of look the other way and you string those words
together in that way, you can totally mean what he is saying,
he means now. Yeah, you totally can. I can totally see that.
He's clarified that. That's fine. But I could have sworn the
idea but the idea that it's bad faith to read it the other way.
No, that's literally what it implies. That's what anyone would
take away from look the other way. I could have sworn and maybe
I'm wrong on this. Totally. I could have sworn there was another
thing where he was like he said specifically like I didn't say
it was okay or whatever. Like I didn't I kept my thoughts I thought
there was some implication he kept his thoughts to himself. But
I I don't know.
No, you are wrong. It's just that now after the fact now he said
it's it's going to change how you look at it. Yeah. Yeah. Well,
that's what I'm saying. Just from that statement, I'm like, "Okay,
I can see it with his It still sounds pretty bad when he does
the look the other way thing." But I'm saying I thought he I
thought there was another clarifying statement where I was like,
"Oh, he really does that." But maybe not. I don't know if I'm
going to look around for it too much. It's a statement
allegation. Destiny allegations for that. Now, he can answer
all these allegations or my questions and what have you on his
own stream and I will move on. I promise you. If he wants to
come out back at me, I'll be happy to answer them. But I tell
you what, if you just say I'm in and conspiracy theories, you're
going to have to deal with one of two things. A, that's going
to leave an empty taste in your audience's mouth. And B, I'm
not the only one. Have a good day. This is such feminine behavior.
What is this? What is this merk clip that you guys are dropping
in my chat? One second. M gets merked.
Let's see. Are you bending over me?
No. USA.
Oh, [__] Looks like M got punched. That'sed up. She's
down at some protest getting That'sed up, dude. Damn. Damn. Are
they both the same clip? They're not the same clip. Sorry. She
screamed this.
I love fascism.
I love ice.
I wonder why she got hit.
Deport them all. Oh, nice.
Mysterious. I have no idea how that could have possibly happened.
That's
shocking. Uh, still disavow. Not good. Not good guys, but okay.
God, we got to finish this up. Commentator. That's your guy.
That's fair. And nobody could be less fair than Chut. He just
needs the image up. You want to call in? Now's your chance.
So, I'm going to go in. Wait, were there good callins or is he
talking to Chud? There is a good call in. There is a good call
in. Oh, yeah. Wait, who called in?
to the other video. See, didn't take 50 minutes. Watch that.
I don't got to pretend. Well, I did pretend not to know in fairness.
I I had no idea what happened in that video. None. He's always
right. You're goddamn right. So, um, are we on anybody in there?
And, uh, by the way, I don't screen any I'm the only guy on this
earth that doesn't screen and, uh, and takes calls on a regular
basis. Nobody calls, I'll get right into the Anisa thing. Who's
wrong about something? Ever apologize to Nobody who's screening
callers?
Nick said I got that up. What happened is I was asking him about
Quayan and he told me about Chud after he called him out drama.
So let's have this private and uh so excuse me I lost my train
of thought. We're going to have to edit that part of the video.
Um so I told I told him not to talk to him or not. And uh what
the [__] was I talking about? I lost my goddamn train
of thought. I am not right. A correction of of of Yeah, you're
making a correction of um Queman apologizing. Oh the queen didn't
apologize. I misunderstood. I asked him so Mike could he responded
about something uh that Chud wanted to get him to. And it is
really interesting that Chud doesn't want to make drama, but
he started the drama. I struggle I struggle personally to believe
that Chud would even entertain the idea for a second that he
could get me to apologize to Nick for watching a video about
him. Personally, that's difficult for me to believe. It could
be true. Maybe Chud said that at some point. I'd struggle to
believe it personally.
h I sorry I agree with you totally. I'm trying to think of like
some other wording that could have happened. Could have been
something along the lines of maybe I'll get Queen to clarify
his position on like the content of the video or the conclusions
of the video thinking you probably disagree with him or something.
Feel like there's something he could have said that would have
sounded like oh Queen will make it clear that you you you don't
suck or
but would have felt legitimate maybe. But then that sort of presupposes
that he watched the McMad video, which I don't think he did.
So, and when it didn't go his way, then he's like, "Hey, let's
let's let's downshift a little." I'm sorry. All these things
adding up, not trustworthy. Real simple. Real simple. I think
it was very telling that he didn't um act like he didn't know
anything, pretended it was from left field, and played stupid
like he always does. I don't trust him. That's it. Can we deal
with that? No more lose. One thing like I said before everything
everything all the narratives that's one of the reasons the queen
goes nuts when you don't have his narrative. If you control the
narrative you control the money. Don't let anybody think for
a minute that this isn't money based. It is everybody even the
good guys. It's a business and if you want to get in the business
you have to control the narrative to somebody. Right. Like I
said even the good ones you can do it the right way and um you
know pick and choose or do actually basically do what Nick's
doing. Hit strike gold while it's hot. Or you can do it like
Chud's doing it. try to discredit credibility and really turn
that into some kind of sneak. Yeah, I don't like that. What a
shock. When all these, you know, you know, Nick's not the first
guy to pass me. Dave passed me at one point. You know, other
guys, Illuminati, lots of people went up, never got jealous.
I figured it's my own fault I'm doing something wrong. But I
honestly believe that he saw the kind of money that Nick's making
and Nick's making a lot of money. And it's really tough to talk
around that. He's always he's got an entire freaking um group
of um chatters calling everybody a sucker, everybody a sweeper,
and he's afraid of them. So he goes with Nick and it it really
makes you ask the question, what does Chud think? I think it's
Clement. Whatever Kleman says, what Jud what does Chud think.
The best thing to happen right now as a drama YouTuber would
be for Ethan Klein to do something so incredibly stupid and um
Nick apologizes for it, which you wouldn't probably do if I had
to guess. Then you would have the argument. Then you would be
able to show why is a sweeper? Why is it bright? He didn't want
to do that. Throw it at you. Throw at you. Throw it at you and
see what happens. That's what they would do. That's why I don't
like them. That's why I don't trust them. And I don't have to.
Anybody in there? No. Not one call. No disagreements. Nothing.
I mean in chat there they've been a bit man. How did nobody call
into this?
Um okay.
Sorry. I mean other than okay examples I showed back. Why would
you listen to Ch right now if you just go to queen and get right
there and it makes
Oh, I see. I like that Tommy is such a fan now. I like Tommy
such a big fan. Counter he's trying to counter Jew the thing.
Well
obviously you should resare this guy. You should get rid of this
guy right now. It's like the most blatant [__] in
the world. Yeah. Like I went to Spicy and I wrote out like what
I thought Chud should do and it was basically like just make
it so Nicholas like kind of sees that this guy's like a liability
like a total liability. He's just a just be like, "Well, my my
relationship's great with Nicholas, so I don't know what he's
talking about." And kind of weird that he's saying he has like
insider knowledge. I hope if people have insider knowledge, they
talk to me, right? You drive a wedge and he's trying to he's
trying to outdo the Jew. It's not going to work. Not going to
work at all. Yeah. Trying to drive a wedge between if Yeah, I
think Oh, Tommy's unlucky. They could do this. If they if they
like actually wanted to try it, they could do this. They've got
like the weight to do it, but uh if it's just Tommy by himself,
it's not going to work. No, I didn't show the Willie thing. I
did do I did show the Tom thing and I gave plenty of examples.
I just did it. So, you can sit there and act like it didn't happen
and that what makes that's what makes you a good Chad fan. Pretend
it didn't happen. That's bad faith. So, well, yeah, obviously
Nick is going to ignore it. That's I Yeah, Nick is not going
to respond. Or Nick is not going to respond publicly. Nick might
have some response privately, possible. All
right. I'm not I'm not I'm not getting trapped into that [__]
I wrote everything down. None of that makes sense. Okay. Well,
I'll let it stand that it doesn't make sense and uh I'll I'll
I'll let the public do what they want with it. Even though I
gave the Willie example, I gave the Oh, here you want one other
example. I don't trust them. I'll give you another one. Um with
the um with the with the Queenman debate, he said, "Hey, you
want to come on here and and talk to this guy?" I was like, "Yeah
sure." No idea who the guy was, right? And then um Oh. Oh, no.
Not the queen. The slasher stuff. When Queen was hunting down
stuff to attack my credibility on the slasher thing. Hey, I got
a message. Hey, Queen to his credibility.
So, one, he already said that it's fine to go after someone if
you've got a specific point. It's the general throwing [__]
the wall trying to attack someone's credibility has an issue
with. Now, all of a sudden, no. No, it's attacking his credibility
to just simply bring up things that he was wrong or misreported
or whatever. Okay, I didn't go and hunt it down. He was leaning
on that story about Slasher to support his idea that there was
a left-wing conspiracy theory against Dr. Disrespect and saying
they all swept for Slasher on that. They swept for Slasher. Okay,
but there was nothing sweet for there was nothing wrong with
what Slasher did. That was that was what I was saying. So, I
was using that to break apart his argument there. So, this idea
that I just went and grabbed it to attack him with, that's not
true. The reason it came up later is because I was telling Aiden
on the stream, I was like, "Yeah, this Tommy C guy, this water
range." Aiden was like, "Do you have any more material criticisms?"
I was like, "I mean, if you want something to look into, if you
want something like cover on stream, have a look at, you know,
is there a complaint for Tommy C here? There's this." And I recommended
the slasher thing, but like that was all out in the open. And
it's like not like I'm going and digging that up. It's just Aiden
asked me, is there something to look into? like it was if you
wanted content or something like
that's that's not I don't see the issue there either. Yeah, sure.
Um I what would be the issue? I I was just thinking of like I
think there is some criticism for Slasher there, but it's just
not it's not like uh everybody sweeps. Also, people didn't sweep.
People bring that up about him being weird with Britney Britney
Venty all the time like constantly. You're talking about the
left wing journalist swept to like Jake Glocky and all these
people
Left wing.
All right. Yeah, I think so. He's like gay. Oh, based uh Nick
100 sorry. Enite says Nick 100% gassed Tommy up to do this so
he didn't have to himself and no one can convince me otherwise.
Nick won't disavow because this is exactly what he thinks. Um
I just don't think Nick would have I think Nick might have vented
about it and then Tommy might have acted on his own. I just don't
think Nick would never ever start like a a fight this way. I
don't even think he I don't think he'd signal to his audience
this way either. I think he can do it much easier like by himself.
I think this makes it like too out there and and makes it so
like I because I think the basically Enite if that's your argument
then Nick has to understand that some people would think that
anyway. And I just think Nick would rather his like soft kind
of like pushing away from people to that if if that were a thing.
I just I don't think that's the best move
personally. I see. Felt like Aiden was implying that. I think
Aiden was implying that it was I think Aiden's implying what
I'm saying that it was just uh Okay. I think I think Aiden was
implying explicitly that Nick was like venting and just mad about
it, which we saw Nick vent and be mad about it in his public
discord, too. So, it is what it
Something along the lines. I am paraphrasing. I'm like, what
are you talking about? So, I didn't show because I know I shouldn't
show. And then Chud shut it down. He went ahead and shut it down
because it was just too stupid. But if you get in the debate,
you might screw up. And considering all these debates on there
are totally bad faith, they pile on. They do all that's a pretty
stupid thing to do. Nobody should go on there to talk. If you're
just going to get piled on, look at the Willie debate between,
I don't know, the entire um incel community. The the leftist
incel,
dude. The entire Willie debate with the leftist incel community.
This guy think I'm a leftist. I paused during the riot stream
last night when they started looting and counted the races coming
out of the store. Is that a leftist? Is that some leftist ideology?
Was I doing leftist theory there or? Oh, community. Right. So,
and then he apologized for me right afterwards. First sign that
I thought something was wrong. By the way, Willie gets a gets
a thing. Hey, Jesus Christ. Hey, there are a lot. It wasn't as
it wasn't as lopsided in any direction as anyone has suspected.
And there was one Asian. Okay, which is shocking. America really
has fallen. Asians are looting. Never before seen. Hey Willie,
I hear you're crashing out. Why don't you come on here and talk?
We get this a lot. Come on here and talk. I heard there's something
wrong. And he's What are you talking about? What's that? Quit
recession indicator. Asians looting. Yeah, exactly.
uh, we're short in the stock market. Okay. Asians eluding. It's
so Yeah, there's another example. He's using in content forming
his own truth, Tommy and Nick fan. I think you all gay. There
might be some truth in that, but why would you say I think you're
all gay when only one of these people is attacking anybody else?
Nick literally doesn't care. Well, Nick might care, but he's
keeping it to himself. Chud doesn't care other than they're going
like, "You're a snake." Ch's like not trying to fight with Nick.
It's just Tommy starting [__] He said something on
stream. He said he made one comment on stream like a week ago.
Jason understand like 10 days ago. Oh, you're talking about um
Yeah, sure.
I mean, technically, if that were the bar, we all have to shut.
Okay. This guy. Okay. Has literally like total like has free
reign on scalping charts right now. But like also like the reason
um the reason obviously like wouldn't care is I think Chud raids
all the time, right? Like he clearly likes
Sorry. Is that Is that not correct? Anyone? Nobody Nobody commenting
probably. Yeah, I think I'm not going to run away from that.
It's drama. That's what it is. It's a guilty pleasure. You don't
need to st There's plenty of money out there. You don't need
to stank everybody. You can be right up front with it. Again,
this this video right here, this is taken from a from a short
that I made criticizing Ethan Klein. And he's sitting there saying
it's impossible to do without during drama. No, you're just on
this. You want to attack credibility. You don't want to attack
his arguments, you know. And you want to say like he said something
nice about either Klein or supported. Well, he's clearly white.
Why?
Willie Mack never crashed out. No, he never did crash out, but
he was trying to was trying to get him in first. By the way,
again, I was sitting in a bowling alley watching all the kids
bowling. That was my job for the day at my kids's birthday party.
And he came out real strong like Willy this up. Willy [__]
that up. I am paraphrasing again. When Nick tweeted what good
job he did, he changed gears completely.
Changed gears completely. They've been trying to get at Willie.
They're trying to get at Tom. People are asking me whether uh
I don't know. I haven't in months.
Dude, this is actually I have to go see I have to go rebuild
this timeline. So, I feel like I have DMs with Chud that like
totally counteract this this argument. I don't want to leak them
or anything,
but like Yeah, you do. What are we doing here? Like at some point
Hold on. Let me Let me check this out. Trying to see like at
some point he um he messaged me about chilling.
One second. One second. One second. Ah, who cares? I don't know.
He messaged me about chilling and I'm like, "Bro, I'm not I'm
like I'm totally chill." You said truce. I think he tried to
get everybody to stop fighting and I was the person who was like,
"Yeah, I don't really I'm not really invested in this fight.
It's fine. That's why Tom stopped streaming. Don't know. But
if he did, I don't blame him. Tom has never really been the fighting
type anyway. You probably should be perfectly honest with you.
So that's enough for me. If it's not enough for you, Batman,
fair enough. But that's enough for me. And I promise I was going
to do this for 50 minutes. So take it. Uh if uh he wants to ignore
it like he kind of ignore what I said this time or he wants to
watch this video, we can go back and forth. No debates. You're
dishonest. You're bad faith. So you're on your own. Uh my advice
to you is instead of um pretending to make Nick has like he has
no credibility, just do it. Just do it. join the crowd. Just
do it, you know. And I think we even said something to the effect
of uh what a conspiracy. Um something comes down the pike uh
with against um Nick Goro and uh Chud just says, "I think it
got Nick. I'm sorry. I got to Yeah, that that Yeah, I still stick
by that. I think that's the plan, but it's going to be a little
harder now." Yeah, I saw Reddit. And uh why would Chud ever disavow
over a disagreement with Nick? Unless it was like literally insane.
Why? over sweeping for Ethan Klein. Ch is going to blow up the
friendship. That's what Tommy's saying right now. Well, where
like Nick literally hasn't responded. Yeah. See, I I think it
was I think it was to do with Nicholas. No, I think it was to
do with Nicholas around the time that a tweet. I think that's
what it was. Um but I sometimes get confused, so I was trying
to look for the timing.
Yeah. Cuz I am aren't as bad as you think. It held at 80. I'll
tell you. But that was like I think it was I I think I'm misunderstanding.
I think it was like basically when I tweeted at Nick and I think
um I man I don't know. I just feel like none of those things
seemed really that bad.
Nick copied Destiny's orbiter white blood cell tactics lol in
her little corner except no one gets laid. Damn. What it was
it held it at 80% and only this morning did it fall down to 70.
I will take that for a guy that holds 2,000 a stream. No problem
any day. There's a lot of mixed feelings about there about Shut
and I think I'm talking about something people couldn't quite
put their finger on or they always believed and said, "Yeah,
I can't believe those guys hang out with him." Yeah, there you
go. That's what I think happened.
Then, yeah, the tactone thing. Yeah, I might watch the tactone
thing. That's kind of funny, too. I got I got to find out more
about that. Really? You have somebody I'm waiting to call. Tactone
Maro, you're on here. Maro. I can't see that. Yeah. Get my name
right. Yeah. Go. What do you want? What the Come on. Jesus Christ.
Cut me a little slack. I've never been on a live stream before.
This is my first time. I'm trying to I'm trying to get comfortable.
This is the wrong show to get comfortable on the first time,
but go ahead. I'm in a good mood. You're in a good mood. I'm
in a good mood. Why are you in a good mood? I don't know. I had
a great day. Easy day.
So funny. I I love moral's a funny guy. Okay. Get your get your
thing. Get your thing. Okay. Listen. Okay. Do you uh do you stand
by the green M&M stuff from like 3 years ago? Yes. Absolutely.
Why would you ask me that? Well, I'm just wonder I mean I I it's
a throwback. I mean you're talking about this Chud Logic guy
you tried to some 17-year-old trans girl with like cone. Who
the cares about that? I don't know about the green M&M. I
have disavowed the green M&M and apologize to Nick for that.
Okay. Cuz I mean, not me. Not me. Not me, Tommy. Some would say
there are little similarities with how you're how you acted with
Nick and then how you acting with Ch. No, there's no similarity.
Here's Okay, I'll answer I'll answer your question. Uh,
is very funny. They threatened me. Nick threatened you. Nick
threatened you. He said he was going to do a video on me over
the green M&M. Not specifically Green M&M. He got a fight
with me. I mean, he threatened me. That's a fact. Did I handle
it? Well, absolutely not. But I Why' you forgive him if he threatened
you? That seems pretty because I had a um he didn't threaten
me. Threat my money is what he did. What I did. Let me let me
answer. Let me answer. Yeah, my bad. No, I haven't. No, I haven't.
Listen, let me let me answer your question. No, he threatened
me and I knew he was on the up and I definitely think with the
overlap of it, if he made me look like a bad guy, he did threaten
me. Whether he's going to fall through on that and another thing
is me, this is four years ago. Me, Augie, Matt, and Nick hashed
it out. Hey, buddy. That's why. That's basically it. Matt, I'm
not explaining every little thing to you, right? I'm [__]
the audience, too. Why? I mean, I can I can put two and two together.
I'm sure this M guy was pretty pretty involved in in the in the,
you know, the threats or whatever. That's what happened. He threatened
me. I probably overreacted. Um, here's another thing, too. I
told the public what happened and I never said another thing
about Mick again. I never took a shot at him. I never did anything
of the sort. I was never ever Why did you forgive him though?
Why'd you forget? Cuz if I because I generally because you're
Tommy C. Shut up. You're so annoying. Bye. All right. Um a
what the [__] No. Why I forgave him is because probably
um a lot of the wounds were healed when we had all Matt and then
um just slowly got back together. It was up to him. We didn't
talk to each other right away. That's it. Nick read me. God.
All right. Well, damn. That seems like it right there. He does
speak a little bit more about at the end of the stream. Really?
You got any idea? Has anybody ever seen that before? I have a
few times. Um, look for when he stops watching politics if we
come down to wind it back a little bit. Like a minute or two.
Yeah. Fun, fun, fun. Calls. I'll take them. But you got to do
it now cuz I want to do it afterwards. And I know he comes in.
Dude, how do these guys string two hours and make a Oh, yeah.
He doesn't make I haven't done I haven't done a call in like
forever.
Yeah. Skip
show, right? And look, I get it. You have people that are just
brain dead. What are you doing? His politics literally come down
to go team and all right, any fans in chat, you've seen this.
He watches a political video or some kind of current events thing
and then he asked the audience to comment, right? And look, I
get it. You have people that are just brain dead uh in there,
but no matter what it is, what are you doing? What are your brain?
What are your Russian brain? We right toward you we left leftwing
lunatic. What are you talking about what it is? If it's like
not his exact opinion, he's like what? Look at me. Yo, man. Have
anybody ever seen that before? I have a few times. I mean, his
politics simply come down to go labor his debating skills. Go
watch uh thoughtful opinions or harmful opinions. Thoughtful
opinions. Eight. W thoughtful opinions.
W Love that bald guy. Oh god. Neil Trump doing something. Gay
Riddler. The gay riddler. You're gay. You're a gay riddler. You're
a gay riddler. I gota be honest with you. when I like I was like
shocked by that video because I got fooled by his uh I'm a thoughtful
person act and that's exactly what it is an act.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Aren't even harmful
opinions like okay? I thought they were okay after that. Yeah,
harmful opinion strikes me as somebody who's like harmful opinions
like I shouldn't say this after tonight cuz I might have actually
burned the Kelly Bridge tonight, but he seems almost like Kelly.
Like probably you're never going to fight with them hard enough
that you could actually like break their brain and make them
hate you. How did you burn the Kelly Bridge? What did you do?
I just pointed out that she just interrupts segments and doesn't
want to participate and generally like
like I don't know if if you're not here to like contribute in
any way. You just want to like kind of sit there like a cat and
make sarcastic comments every once in a while. Then maybe there's
a different place you should go. What else do you bring her on
stream for?
Uh I wanted her to just read some logs with me today and she
was just like, "No, I don't want to do that. I don't want to
do that. These people are gay furries." And I'm like, "Yeah,
but it's funny." Then she brought in Then he brought in her biggest
OP.
And yeah, I did do that. I did bring on her biggest OP to But
unfortunately, her biggest OP was also the most qualified to
do it. So, what am I supposed to do?
Yeah. What are you supposed to do? Sending this clip to Kelly.
I I was probably like too mean, but it's like I at some point
I'm just like kind of done when it's like, "Hey, I I'd like to
do like this segment." Um, and like I actually wanted to run
tight and she like brings up a diff a totally different story
in the middle of it. I was like, "Okay, if you can't like you
can't follow like a coherent line of thought, then I guess I
need to sit outside of this Discord for a while and run those
segments and then I can join this and we do open calls or something."
Yeah, it was worth it. Saything. No, he got 50 subs for it. How
is he seething? He's sthing. He's mad. I didn't get 50 subs for
it. It was not bad. But I Yeah, should probably apologize to
Kelly. I was like I was probably too mean, but like I don't know.
I feel like what I should do is instead of arguing with her,
I should just say, "Hey, just so you know, um you're like interrupting
the segment. I'm going. That's actually what I should do instead
of like getting in an argument and trying to help her understand
what's going on." Or I, you know, uh that's not what happened
there. I'm lying. I was just like you, Kelly. Yeah, that's more
what it was like to be fair. Kelly's Kelly always around like
that all the time. All the time. All the time. And like sometimes
it's fine, but sometimes it's really annoying. And then she's
like, "No, I just want to sit here and like laugh." I'm like,
"Okay." And before anybody says that like Kenny just sat there
and laughed, Kenny offered to read and then we just didn't need
him to read. Kenny was down to read. I'm not owned. I'm not owned.
I'm not owned. I'm not owned.
I prayed to God and God like answered me. This is a good deer
paid. Didn't have to read. And he parked. Yeah. And I know a
little Kelly doesn't want to get paid for the stream. And like
it's totally fine if she doesn't want to, but also like unfortunately
she's just a like she's literally like a damaged grenade when
she's in a voice call and the topic isn't something she wants
to do. She'll just like start talking about whatever else. She'll
totally derail all the time. So, you know, sometimes that's funny.
Sometimes I don't want to do that. That's all. That's all. And
I'm watching this thing and like I I look, you could disagree
with thoughtful opinions. He's not like crazy. Anything anything
outside of their opinions if you don't how many times is she
going to correct him and he's not going to pick it up. The sharing
with them you're crazy, stupid, scenile, dishonest. It's never
like I hate to say I disagree. Everything has to your character.
It's never attack on the actual opinions. You're not attacking
your opinions harmful. All of them. Dishonest prick. Just call
me a then. No, I didn't. I didn't even infer it. Oh, wait a minute.
He had opinions. Yeah, I know. No, but he had a different take
on the By the way, I agree with it. And I What's another point?
Me and Nick argued about that offline. You know that. I was like,
I think I think on the Mr. Beast thing. I like I thought harmful
opinions have a has a point. And he was like, no. It was a long
conversation. And then what he did is he went on a stream with
like 3,000 people and told everybody what a guy I was. That's
a nickname. Can we p this bro? We cannot fix this bro. You haven't
been around long enough. There's some you let go and some you
don't let go. And then somebody come back to and you don't come.
This guy is dishonest. I'm sorry. And honestly, we weren't that
tight to begin with. I liked him. I like the show until I started
slowly realizing I'm not getting used for content here. Oh, wait
a minute. What's going on in that stream? The Boax thing. Is
that necessary? I I finally make a video call out. What's going
on? I'm sorry. I'm not sitting down with anybody who has a shout.
Yeah, we'll be fine. We'll be entertain. And no, I'm not going
on any interviews or or debate. Anybody call in here anytime
friends now? You got no friends. Cleveland's taking a shot. Why
would you Why ask yourself if you wanted those opinions?
Why would you watch Chud when you could always watch Wayman and
he can have the takes and say this that Chud's afraid to say.
So because you might off the wrong person while he's calling
out Nick for Friday and then he asked him to talk about it offline
because there's no criticism about that problem. No, of course.
Yeah. He says you can talk to me in public or private if you'd
like to say well I'll talk to public. I I don't want anyone here.
You can take apart my arguments here. It's a lot easier anyway.
Actually the reason I like it here is he can't just call me names
like the the gay riddler or something like that. He he has to
respond which is why I didn't play the V. I'm gonna leave it
that. Let's go. I have enough this [__] Um, if you
have you, we're doing a what's called Wow. Show. I don't even
mind. You know, you know what's really tragic about this? Going
back to the first bit is that Chud will again not watch the video
at all and will not respond materially to anything Tommy said.
Very sad. Very unfortunat.
Yeah, very unfortunate. Even the chat, you learn from the best.
Sure. Crazy. All right. You know what? We're not doing after
show. Um, wow. Listen, I want to go in. We might watch something
together as a group. So, I'll be in there. How about that? I
just don't want that. I want a little more freedom um instead
of not that it's that much pressure. We don't sit in there and
hang out together. I usually stay a lot when I do that cuz it
just seems like he's contrarian all the things. It's like a train
[__] opinion. All these opinions are based on [__]
money. Guy would blow Hitler to get a hit, you know, and that's
what's frustrating him sometimes. You know, you got look the
way I see. You should never make that criticism of Chud cuz Chud
will just own that criticism and make you look silly for making
it. Well, they blow Hitler. This guy likes money. Yeah, I do
like money. Yes, I will farm dead Palestinian kids for money.
I just saw a clip the other day. Yes, I will farm dead Palestinian
children for money. Yes, I did do that. I will do that and I
make a lot of money doing it. Right. He'll just make you look
silly for trying to do them. I don't know why Tommy's making
that argument or why he's made that point. Can we appreciate
Chud's attempts to deescalate failed and heating things up? No,
that's not at all true. Literally, literally
0%. It's not heated up at all. There's like nothing going to
h That's why this is so to watch cuz it's like it's funny watching
Tommy be or whatever, but there's nothing is going to happen.
Nobody will talk to anyone. Nothing interesting will happen.
Nothing ever happens. Where's a Nick clip? Someone's sending
me the Nick clip right now. Black P again. Nothing ever happens.
Blackp again, dude. Nothing ever happens. That the nothing ever
happens. Chud, I want to kill him. Every time I see like whenever
anything happens, I think of his face. Whenever anything in the
world starts to happen, I see his face in my mind. In my mind's
eye, it haunts me. I know that it will end up being nothing again.
He always wins. Oh boy, would you look at the time I
And it's like no, no,
no, not again. Every time. Every time you're thinking he will
be defeated, it's like finally. Every time something happens,
you're
finally you're going to die. You know this. Nothing ever happens.
Chad will will
lose. And every time he's undefeated, every time. The arc of
history is long, but it bends towards the nothing ever happens
chut. You think maybe it'll happen just this once. But it never
happens. Nothing ever happens. Literally never happens.
God, you might not like Ethan Klein. You might not like Nick
benefiting from like Ethan Klein. Why wouldn't you? What they
[__] did to him? You might even think Nick's like
running it on a little thick. What you wouldn't do is is call
attack his credibility. Rider is a credibility attack. That's
Yeah, that's a credibility very termed. You should be very careful
how you throw that around, man. I think that's racist. You just
attacking AV now. True anymore. Racist.
Racist. Yo, [__] this racist.
[__] this racist.
He's from Ger and he's in Germany, too. Let's go. It's kind of
naughty. It's kind of funny. [__] You good?
Is he good? You good? He never met. I was like, somebody wrote
me like you're completely clean with you. You just want to make
one mistake. No, he did. So,
is this is is I my real question here. Okay. And I think this
is this should be everybody's question. All right. Because it's
a real concern.
If Tommy C is going to consistently allege wrongdoing on the
behalf of one man with no evidence whatsoever in a totally conspiratorial
way. At what point do Ethan Klein and Nick Dario call him out?
Somebody who is very closely affiliated. Now I need help. This
is just blatant
I've never seen more blatant anti-semitism. Okay. Tommy C is
one stream away from sending skulls to Queman's address. Okay.
It's disgusting. All right. If Quimman had kids, he would call
CPS. You know, I think Tommy Tommy C actually moved to Germany
as a dog whistle to with me actually. You know, I think I I'm
pretty sure he deleted. He knows the Nazi country. He He It has
to be intentional, dude. I'm pretty sure he deleted a stream
where he you in a video game unironically. I think he did that.
But realistically, yeah, I I'm pretty sure if people made this
up about Ethan Klene, okay, if they were making up all of these
positions about Ethan Klein, some people would be there to call
out the anti-semitism, but when it's a when it's a young man
who doesn't like you, well, then it's just fine. We can just
make up You know what? Queman controls the media, guys. Okay.
All All of your Chud All of your Chud logic stuff, all programmed
by Queen, 100%. Okay? I got Chud streams. It's facts.
I res I I'm sitting here. I do my stream, but he still has to
come and sit here for like, you know, 2, three hours a night
and give his opinions cuz he can't risk independent media prospering.
Okay. Got to keep us under the grers's thumb. It's very, very,
very disingenuous. Okay. How do I decapitate Chuds? They're losers.
Jesus. I don't do that.
What are we talking about here? Oneover is losing it. Anyway,
I do think it's funny though cuz I like as much as that's all
joking. Uh it's also just totally true. Like I I think if could
you imagine somebody having basically like some narrative about
Ethan Klein that they couldn't back up at all that was like only
vaguely tied to anything and alleged a bunch of like conspiratorial
backroom dealing that was going on like to with you. I I feel
like absolutely about the ADL [__] The ADL [__]
is out in the open. Everyone can see it. So it's not even a question
man. If if Queman was on that side, Stardust would literally
open up this Tommy C stream and Wow. Wow. Wow. J you are really
doing that right now. Wow. Can we archive this? Is he going to
delete this? Can we archive this? Oh my god. Oh my god. I just
want I just want some evidence. Okay. The next time Tommy starts
saying Quimman totally some clips like I listen how do you get
more good faith than we go back we listen to this clip. We go,
"Oh, now that he's explained it, like I could see how maybe he
could mean either one." And it's just all watching him speak.
It's not any like none of us just like characterizing what he's
saying, right? It's like, "Oh, he explained it." And yeah, we
go back and watch it. Oh, now we can kind of see it. I want to
know why the Chuds are right when I saw three marriages end in
three marriages in one weekend. The are you talking about one
to the happening?
He's going through a rough time. That is a good one. Handogle.
Yes. Chud's Chud's one bad take away from Queenman shutting down.
Don't trust that hoger guy. Do not trust that hendog guy. You
know what the guy said in my kick chat earlier? He said some
like it it was like trying quite a bait him. It was like I would
I would enjoy to pet like a dog. Oh, is that is that like uh
really really weird
um spoiler?
Yo, what's up, bro? I just said earlier when I saw that Pirate
Software started erping with somebody who donated him $800, I'll
offer that same thing to you. Okay. $800 donation. I'll I'll
call you my little wuff. Okay. Just saying if that's who you
are, you could be my little woof. Okay. Only 800 bucks. What
are we doing here? Just a little gay ERP for $800. What are you
talking about? What do you mean what are we doing here? How is
it confusing what we're doing here? He doesn't appreciate the
ERP stream. Okay. All right. All right, guys. That's probably
it for today. Um this guy for two hours again. I'm a Tommy C
fan. I didn't mean anything I said, dude. I was. Yeah. Okay,
guys. We're not here tomorrow. We need uh we need a day off.
It's possible Wednesday's stream will also be quite short. Uh
and then Thursday, I think we're back to normal stream. I will
glaze you. I will do tricks on it.
Reverse cowgirl. Do reverse cowgirl. I'll giggle when it pops
out. Put it back in. Giggling and slipping it back in. Glazing.
I may have seen this clip before. I don't know if you can tell.
Crispy cream dozens glaze attack. If you put something that is
good in the and I do everybody. Well, okay. Pause. I will glaze
you. He's the best.
He's the best. He's a funny guy. He's a funny guy. Okay. All
right. Good night, guys. Be back tomorrow. See you. Good night.
Goodbye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Good night.